My name is Jordan and I'm from Indiana.
我叫乔丹，来自印第安纳州。
Last summer I started my third viewing of how I met your mother.
去年夏天，我开始第三次重温《老爸老妈浪漫史》。
My first girlfriend had just broken up with me, and the show felt like the only thing that could get me through those first three days.
我的初女友刚和我分手，这部剧感觉像是唯一能陪我度过最初那三天的事物。
I remember watching Return of the Shirt very distinctly.
我清楚地记得自己看《一件衬衫的回归》那一集时的情景。
I was practically shouting at Ted the entire episode.
那一整集我几乎都在冲着泰德大喊大叫。
While the topic hit a little close to home at that point, I realized how interesting it was to be able to view this show with that new perspective, one of someone who had been broken up with.
虽然当时这个话题有点戳中我的痛处，但我意识到，能以这种全新的视角——一个刚经历分手的人的视角——来欣赏这部剧，是一件多么有趣的事。
I think that's the beauty of this show.
我想这就是这部剧的魅力所在。
I get something new out of it every single time I watch it.
每次我看，都能从中获得新的感悟。
I'll be soon in New York City, when I see you, please permit me to tell you everything of city.
我很快就要去纽约市了，等见到你时，请允许我和你讲讲关于这座城市的一切。
Hello, welcome to how we made your mother.
大家好，欢迎来到《我们是如何创造老爸老妈的》。
I'm Josh Radner.
我是乔什·拉德诺。
I am joined as ever by my dear friend and how I met your mother co-creator Craig Thomas.
和往常一样，陪伴我的有我的挚友、《老爸老妈浪漫史》的联合创作者克雷格·托马斯。
Hello, Craig.
你好，克雷格。
Hey, Josh.
嘿，乔什。
We're talking about episode four, season one, return of the shirt.
我们要聊的是第一季第四集，《一件衬衫的回归》。
This episode aired when, Alec.
这一集是什么时候播出的，亚历克。
On October 10th, 2005.
在2005年10月10日。
October 10th, 2005, nearly 20 years ago, it's so long ago, it's so long ago.
2005年10月10日，快20年前了，太久远了，真的太久远了。
I can't handle it.
我简直不敢面对。
Okay.
好的。
Who do we have joining us today?
今天和我们一起连线的都有谁？
I'm very excited to have our guest today appropriately enough.
我非常高兴能请到今天的嘉宾，可以说是再合适不过了。
We have the writer of this episode, return the shirt.
我们请到了这一集《一件衬衫的回归》的编剧。
In the entire amount of amateur mother, there were only two writers who were there from day one, from the pilot, like the pilot punch up session, right?
在整部《老爸老妈浪漫史》中，从第一天、从试播集起就在的编剧只有两位，就像试播集润色会议那样，对吧？
Hired onto the show on the pilot, there are 208 episodes, two writers.
从试播集就被雇用到剧组，一共208集，只有两位编剧。
Chris Harris, another awesome all-timer who got to it at some point, and the other one is our guest today.
克里斯·哈里斯，另一位在某个阶段加入的传奇人物，而另一位就是我们今天的嘉宾。
The writer of the show, Courtney Kang.
本剧的编剧，考特尼·康。
Courtney Kang.
考特尼·康。
Hi, Courtney.
嗨，考特尼。
Yeah.
耶。
Thank you so much for having me.
非常感谢邀请我来。
Oh my God, we're so happy you're here.
天哪，你能来我们太高兴了。
Thanks for giving us a decade of your life, by the way.
顺便说一句，谢谢你把十年的青春奉献给我们。
Thanks for that.
谢谢你。
Yeah.
对。
Thanks for that decade.
谢谢你那十年。
A full decade.
整整十年。
Yes.
是的。
What?
什么？
Like, did we carry?
比如说，我们都过30岁了吗？
I don't think we got to 40, right?
我记得我们还没到40岁吧？
You were both on our 30s and almost got, I think I'm a little older than you.
我们当时都30多岁，差不多快到……我觉得我比你稍大一点。
I think it'd be just shy of 40 when we did our 30s on how I met your mother, right?
我觉得拍《老爸老妈浪漫史》的时候，我们30多岁，离40岁只差一点点，对吧？
That's pretty much it.
差不多就是这样。
I always tell people I started the show in my late 20s.
我总是跟别人说我加入剧组时快30岁。
I was, I think I was like 28 or 29.
我当时大概28或29岁吧。
I started the show like single.
我进剧组时还是单身。
I had just started dating my now husband and I left the show a mother of two like staring down 40.
我刚开始跟我现在的丈夫约会，而我离开剧组时已经是两个孩子的妈妈了，正面对着40岁的到来。
So it was those like, And I feel like what was great about it is all of us, we're kind of in that sort of same age bracket and we were going through what the gang was going through and that was totally informing the stories, like Lilian Marshall getting married, starting to have children, career stuff, like we were going through it with the gang and I think it was like, and we were all going through it.
所以就是那些……而且我觉得最棒的是，我们大家基本上都在同一个年龄段，我们经历着主角团正在经历的事情，而这完全为故事提供了灵感，比如莉莉和马修结婚、开始生孩子、职业上的事，我们和主角团一起经历着这一切，而且我觉得，当时我们所有人都在经历这些。
You know, the cast was going through their things, the writers, the crew, everybody.
你知道，演员们在收拾他们的东西，编剧们，剧组人员，所有人都在。
It wasn't like the Hollywood, you know, 28 year olds playing high school students kind of like silliness.
这不像好莱坞那种，你知道的，28岁的人去演高中生的那种无聊把戏。
Like we were, we were in the pocket of the era that we were, we were showing, you know?
就像我们，我们正处于我们所展现的那个时代的内核中，你知道吗？
And the writing, the writing staff wasn't like these grizzled veterans who'd been doing it lots of years.
而且剧本创作团队也不像那种干了很多年的老油条。
And if this show doesn't work out, we'll go on to some other show like this was our shot, right?
觉得如果这部剧不行了，我们还可以去搞别的剧，这就好像是我们的绝佳机会，对吧？
This was our show.
这就是我们的剧。
This was going to be our show.
这将会是属于我们的剧。
We're the same age as the cast, Courtney, you were a little younger than me, but we were basically contemporaries and it felt like we were all sharing material and sharing stories and we all spoke the same language and I think that was like so key.
我们和演员们年龄相仿，考妮，你比我小一点，但我们基本上是同龄人，感觉我们都在分享素材和故事，我们都说同一种语言，我觉得这才是最关键的。
It's really interesting.
这真的很有趣。
Okay, so return of the shirt is of course a dating episode.
好吧，所以“衬衫归来”当然是一集关于约会的剧集。
It's not a relationship episode.
它不是一集关于恋爱的剧集。
It's like dating hell return of the shirt.
这就好像是约会地狱，“衬衫归来”。
You were like talk about do you remember because I don't where the idea originally came from of like that idea of going back to that person going back to that a person who's stuck in the back of your head and you go, wait a second.
你当时说，聊聊——你还记得吗，因为我记不清了——最初那个想法是从哪来的，就是那种回到那个人身边、回到那个一直卡在你脑海深处的人身边，然后你想，等一下。
Why don't I try that again?
我为什么不再试一次呢？
Like, was that from, I forget if that was from your life or that was the room, just that specific thing of, I'm going to excavate back and find this person.
比如，那是源于，我忘了那是来自你的生活还是编剧室的构思，就是那种具体的情节：我要去深挖过去，把这个人找出来。
Maybe that was the right person.
也许那才是对的人。
Did that come from your life?
这源于你的生活吗？
I forget.
我忘了。
I think there were like two sort of fundamental truths that we got to that I think I might have brought to the room or that we sort of like build on or maybe somebody else did.
我觉得大概有两个某种根本性的真相，可能是被我带到了编剧室，或者我们在此基础上进行了延伸，又或者其他人也有贡献。
I'm I'm not exactly sure, but the idea of it really being hard to break up with someone, rang, always rang very true to me.
我记不太清了，但“和某人分手真的很艰难”这个想法，一直让我觉得非常真实。
And I'm kind of like a path of least resistance person.
我这人有点倾向于走阻力最小的路。
And so I would just sort of like, ah, it's just easier to go along with this.
所以我通常会觉得，啊，顺其自然反而更容易。
And so I think like that was one of the germs of the idea of like, oh, like it's hard to break up with people.
所以我觉得这算是那种萌芽的想法之一，比如，哦，跟别人分手太难了。
And also the idea that it's so easy look back and reminisce and be like, hey, that person was great.
还有那种想法，就是回首过去和追忆往事是如此轻松，会觉得：嘿，那个人真棒。
Like, maybe, maybe there's something there.
比如，也许，也许事情还有转机。
Like that's, you know, like, well, why didn't that work out?
就像那种，你知道的，嗯，为什么当时没有成呢？
And you sort of like, you know, you, you, you, you talk yourself into things, you know, and I think it's a little bit like wanting to rewrite history.
然后你就会，你知道的，你、你、你会说服自己接受某些事情，你知道的，我觉得这有点像想要改写历史。
It's a little bit the romantic idea of like, I've changed, you know, and so I think it was like, I think that's what I loved about the rewatch of this episode, I think it's grounded and there's these two very universal ideas that we all fall victim to.
这有点像那种浪漫的想法，比如“我已经变了”，你知道的，所以我觉得，这就是我喜欢重温这一集的地方，我觉得它很接地气，里面包含着两个我们所有人都会沦陷的普世观点。
Yeah, it makes me think one thing about the agony of breakups and it's agonizing to be broken up with, but I have found it no less agonizing to break up with someone, especially if you care about them obviously, you've spent some significant time with them presumably, But also, like, I just don't like hurting people's feelings, right?
是的，这让我想起关于分手痛苦的一点，被甩固然痛苦，但我发现主动跟别人分手也同样痛苦，特别是如果你显然在乎他们的话，你可能和他们共度了相当长的一段时间，而且，我也只是不喜欢伤害别人的感情，对吧？
Like, I avoid it at all costs, and there's something about the inability to have hard conversations, actually makes things much worse.
比如，我竭力避免这样做，而某种无法进行艰难对话的无能，实际上会让事情变得更糟。
You end up making much more terrible decisions that hurt people.
你最终会做出更多伤害别人的糟糕决定。
And I also love that idea of the kind of, like, euphoric recall of a relationship.
我也很喜欢那种对一段感情的“欣快回忆”的想法。
Like, you don't remember why you broke up with her.
比如，你不记得当初为什么要和她分手了。
You just, it's like, the highlight real of relationship comes back to you and you're like, they were delightful.
你只是，这就好像，感情的精彩集锦回到了你的脑海里，你会觉得：他们太美好了。
What was my problem?
我当时有什么毛病？
And then you think it must have been me.
然后你会觉得一定是我自己的问题。
It couldn't have been.
绝对不可能是对方的问题。
And I've tried to revisit some of those things.
我也曾尝试重温过其中一些事情。
And you go in with the best of intentions.
你怀着最好的意图去面对。
And it's astonishing how quickly you get back to the place where you're like, oh, yeah, this was never, this wasn't right.
但惊人的是，你很快就会回到那种状态，你会觉得：哦，对了，这根本不对，这从来就不合适。
It's not that they're a bad person.
并不是说他们是个坏人。
It's not that I'm the bad person.
并不是说我是个坏人。
In the episode, it is astonishingly fast.
在这一集里，这种转变快得惊人。
It's very tough.
这真的很难。
It's very it's like I almost wish as every time you watch an episode now the my wife and I said we're rewatching it I go I wish we had five more minutes in this episode you know you think I was 25 and said a 22 because I'm like That felt very fast, but I guess that was also kind of the joke just like the second he gets her back He says I've got to get out of this which is funny.
这真的很——就好像我几乎希望，现在每次看一集的时候，我和我妻子说我们在重看，我都会想：我希望这集能再多给我们五分钟，你知道的，你可能会想我当时25岁却演了个22岁的，因为我觉得这进展太快了，但我想这也是笑点所在，就像他刚把她追回来说的那样：“我得赶紧离开这儿，”这挺搞笑的。
It is funny.
这确实挺搞笑的。
It's funny, but it's also brutal It's like yeah, what are you doing?
搞笑是搞笑，但这也太残酷了。
Yeah, yeah, and you know why you don't know he doesn't ever show his work That's it.
就像是，天哪，你在干什么？
No, that was my that was it.
对啊，对啊，而且你知道为什么吗？你不知道，他从来不展示他的心路历程，就是这样。
He's just he never even explains why it's really is he just it's enough Oh, yeah, so Courtney also do you remember like where the the shirt that kind of talismanic object of the episode came from?
不，那就是我的，这就是全部。他甚至从不解释原因，真的就是——这就足够了。哦，对了，考妮，你还记得这集的那个衬衫——那种堪称护身符的物件——是从哪来的吗？
I was I can't remember I couldn't remember that I feel like that was your pitch I feel like that like that idea of going back in your like the shirt is this key that unlocks a door into the past that leads to her right?
我是……我记不清了，我记不得了，我觉得那是你的点子，我觉得那种回到过去的设想，就好像这件衬衫是打开通往过去大门的钥匙，能引领你找到她，对吧？
Like I don't know.
就像我不知道一样。
How do we get there?
我们是怎么做到的？
I can't remember how we got there.
我记不得我们是怎么做到的了。
I think I think it might have been a Carter thing that like the shirt that it like the shirt somehow connected it to the I don't I don't think I'm not.
我觉得，我觉得那可能是卡特（Carter）的点子，比如这件衬衫，这件衬衫不知怎么的把它和……我觉得，我觉得不是，我不是。
That feels like it could be a Carter thing.
感觉这挺像卡特会有的点子。
Like Carter we come in with a new shirt and have a new personality.
就像卡特换了件新衬衫就换了个新性格一样。
Be like yeah.
就好像，对。
Yeah.
对。
I maybe it was a a room thing.
我，也许这是编剧室里的某个点子。
To be honest, I can't really remember.
说实话，我真的记不清了。
But you know what?
但你知道吗？
What's in.
有什么……
Oh, go please, go.
哦，请说，请说。
No, I'm just going to say that's a good portrait of like what it's like to me in a writer's room because sometimes you know what you pitch.
不，我只是想说，这很好地描绘了编剧室的工作状态，因为有时你知道什么是你提出的点子。
And sometimes it's just like this hive mind kind of if we ask that entire room whose idea it was, it might be like, I don't know.
有时它就像是一种集体思维，如果我们问整个编剧室那是谁的主意，大家可能会说：“我不知道。”
Yeah.
对。
Totally.
完全是这样。
It's just an interesting writer's room observation.
这真是一个有趣的编剧室现象。
We keep going.
我们继续吧。
I got you off.
我打断你了。
No, it's also, it's also like a writer's room observation is like like things that I'm like, I think that was me.
不，这也是，这也是一种编剧室现象，比如有些事我觉得“我想那是我的主意”。
I have this like fear some writers listening to be able to be like, that was my idea.
我有一种恐惧，有些编剧听了可能会觉得：“那是我的点子，她怎么敢这么说。”
How dare she.
天哪。
Oh my God.
我的天呐。
I see that every time.
我每次都这样。
I'm like, I got three kids.
我会想，我有三个孩子，我根本不记得自己说过什么，我什么都不记得了。
I don't know what I said.
我什么都不记得了。
I don't know anything anymore.
In thinking about the inception of the idea, I remember one thing that the room got really excited about was your character previous to this episode had been pining, had been interested in Robin and had been going after her.
回想这个点子的最初构思，我记得编剧室里有一件事让大家非常兴奋，那就是在这一集之前，你的角色一直在苦苦思念罗宾（Robin），一直对她感兴趣，一直在追求她。
And I remember we got really excited about the idea of kind of flipping the switch and putting you in the position where your character someone wanted you.
我记得我们对这种反转的想法感到非常兴奋，就是把角色置于这样一个位置：有人想要你，而你是那个不得不去伤害他们的人。
And you were the one that had to break their heart.
而你是那个不得不去伤害他们的人。
And also I think it sort of helped to build up the Ted character of, he's this romantic guy who desperately wants to fall in love and wants the great girl.
而且我也觉得这有助于塑造泰德（Ted）这个角色，他是一个浪漫的家伙，拼命想要坠入爱河，想要找到一个好姑娘。
But also he's a character who women want and who women want to fall in love with.
但他也是一个受女性欢迎、让女性想要与之坠入爱河的角色。
but it's not that easy.
但事情没那么简单。
It has to be someone great.
那必须是个非常棒的人。
And so I think it kind of did good series groundwork.
所以我觉得这为整个剧集打下了良好的基础。
Yeah.
对。
But it's like Ted's not just a guy that pines after girls and he could get lots of girls.
但这就像是说，泰德不仅仅是一个追着女孩跑的家伙，他也能追到很多女孩。
He's had this history.
他有这样一段历史。
And so like put your character in this different light.
所以把你的角色置于这种不同的光芒下。
I think it was like, it was a new sort of like color for Ted.
我觉得这就像是为泰德增添了一种新的色彩。
That's how we got there.
我们就是这样构思出来的。
And that's the kind of through line that gets you to an idea.
这就是引导你产生灵感的贯穿线索。
Because I think we did.
因为我觉得我们确实这么做了。
We said, let's give that extra dimension to Ted.
我们说过，让我们为泰德赋予这个额外的维度。
And I also remember, you're making me remember this, we said, let's scuff Ted up a little in this one.
我也记得，你让我想起了这一点，我们说过，这一集里我们要让泰德稍微有点瑕疵。
Let's make Ted in the right.
让我们让泰德站在有理的一方。
You know what I mean?
你知道我的意思吗？
Like he's, he can't just be this guy who gives great speeches and says all the right things and stuff just the stars on the line, but he's always going to be in the right Ted fucked up in this one.
就像他不能只是那种发表精彩演讲、说尽所有正确的话、一切都顺风顺水的人，但他总会在对的地方——泰德这次确实搞砸了。
Like he did.
就像他确实搞砸了一样。
He did.
他确实砸了。
This was a bad.
这回太糟了。
Totally.
完全是。
And like with most Ted, Ted screw ups, he has visible bruises and injuries to show for it.
而且就像泰德的大多数失误一样，他身上有清晰可见的淤青和伤痕。
I think this is the first time, like, that shows up black and blue, but not the last.
我觉得这是他第一次被打得青一块紫一块的，但绝不是最后一次。
And I wrote you this little ditty to send you in New York City.
我为你写了这首小曲，送你去纽约市。
We'll be right back.
我们马上回来。
And now, back's the show.
现在，言归正传。
I mean, it's very check-off.
我的意思是，这非常契诃夫。
The idea that this shirt is in Act One, and then in Act Three, the shirt has to get destroyed.
也就是第一幕里出现了这件衬衫，到了第三幕，衬衫就得被毁掉。
It has to explode.
它必须得爆掉。
Yes, the shirt is hung up over the fireplace.
没错，这件衬衫就像是挂在壁炉上的枪。
It must be shot and I remember I love scenes that have no words that are very effective.
它就得开枪，而且我记得我非常喜欢那些没有台词却极具表现力的场景。
I'm always has a screenwriter trying to write them.
我作为编剧总是尝试去写这样的场景。
I remember shooting the Ted looking through his closet and then seeing the shirt and pulling it out.
我记得拍摄泰德翻找衣柜，然后看到那件衬衫并把它抽出来。
I think I said, like, it almost feels like Samuel L.
我想我当时说过，这就感觉像是塞缪尔·L·
Jackson's briefcase in politics.
杰克逊在《低俗小说》里的公文包。
It's like coming off of it.
自带一种发光特效。
And I remember we might have talked about this crack, but I remember I've such a strong strong memory, and it's so funny that this was nearly 20 years ago, Courtney, but when I walk into the bar wearing the shirt, and I think it's Ali who speaks first, Lily.
我记得我们可能聊过这个笑话，但我有特别深刻的记忆，而且真搞笑，这已经是近20年前的事了，考特尼，但当我穿着那件衬衫走进酒吧时，我记得是阿里先开口的，莉莉。
I forget what she says, like, woo, look at Mr. Shirt or something.
我忘了她说什么了，好像是，哇，瞧瞧衬衫先生什么的。
And I said, right, right.
然后我说，对啊，对啊。
And I remember in the run through, you just died at that.
我记得在排练时，你听到这个直接笑喷了。
Like you thought it was so funny.
就觉得这太搞笑了。
And we couldn't remember if it just says, right, or if it was right, right.
我们当时记不清台词里只是一个“对”，还是两个“对，对”。
But somehow right, right, became a kind of mosebyism.
但不知怎的，“对，对”成了一种莫斯比式的口头禅。
Like from that moment on, it was kind of like right, right, we did that hundreds of times I feel.
从那一刻起，就像是“对，对”，我觉得我们在剧里这么说过几百次。
In the show.
在剧里。
Yeah.
是的。
Yes, yes.
对，对。
Right.
对。
I love the remember Courtney laughing at that.
我喜欢记得考特尼当时笑得前仰后合。
Courtney, you're so new.
考特尼，你当时还挺新。
You're kind of like, is this working?
你心里大概在想，这真的行得通吗？
And then you're like, oh, the writer of the episode likes this.
然后你又想，哦，这集的编剧很喜欢这个。
Like that felt good.
那种感觉挺棒的。
Yeah.
对。
And she's laughing at your performance.
而且她是在笑你的表演。
She's not arrogantly laughing at it.
她不是那种傲慢地嘲笑。
How funny is my jet?
“我的笑话多好笑啊”那种。
Like that was just right.
就真的很自然。
It's legitimately laughing at you.
那是实打实地在笑你。
But I also love Marshall's line Hot Top, bro.
不过我也很喜欢马歇尔的那句台词，“火辣上衣，兄弟”。
I've not always stayed with me.
这句话一直留在我脑海里。
Brow.
兄弟。
Hot Top, bro.
火辣上衣，兄弟。
Just one more thing about the kind of scuffing up Ted as someone who's, who both desires and is desired and also gets his heart broken and breaks hearts.
关于把泰德弄得狼狈一点，还有一点想说：他是一个既渴望爱又被人渴望，同时又会心碎和让人心碎的人。
Like I think if you're, if you're in the dating game long enough, you're gonna play all the roles.
我觉得吧，如果你在情场混得够久，各种角色你都会扮演过。
So it's not quite honest to just say like, Oh, this is a guy who always gets his heart broken or this is a guy who's always like leaving.
所以，简单地说“哦，这是一个总是心碎的家伙”或者“这是一个总是选择离开的家伙”，并不是那么客观。
Like, if you're in the game long enough, I don't like that, turn the game.
我是说，如果你在场子里混得够久——我不喜欢“场子”这个词。
But if you're out there long enough, you do end up kind of being a hero in a villain depending on the night, you know?
但如果你在外面混得够久，根据不同的夜晚，你到头来既会当英雄，也会当恶棍，你知道吗？
Yeah, and I like that this episode, like Ted has real flaws.
对，而且我喜欢这一集的地方在于，泰德有真正的缺点。
Like, you know, like, it's not just, oh, he's just like shining night and shining armor, you know?
你知道的，就好像，他不仅仅是个身披闪亮铠甲的骑士，对吧？
Like, I remember there was a few moments on set with Carter that I think Ted not always behaving correctly is sometimes tough, tough for Carter.
我记得在片场和卡特有过几次交流，我觉得泰德有时表现得不够得体，对卡特来说可能有点难，有点难接受。
Did you know what I mean?
你知道我的意思吗？
Yeah.
嗯。
Because I remember Carter.
因为我记得卡特。
There was like a few moments of him being like, is this okay?
他曾有过几次这样的反应：“这样行吗？”
Is this, is this bad?
“这，这样不好吗？”
Is this too much?
“这会不会太过分了？”
And I remember there was like a few moments.
我记得有那么几次。
I was like, you know, like, you know, because you're, it's in the beginning.
我就说，你知道的，因为你正处于开始阶段。
You're just sort of like testing it out.
你只是在某种程度上进行试水。
Yeah, it's a, it's a four.
对，这是一个，这是一个四。
It's a four.
这是一个四。
I mean, yeah.
我是说，对。
So you're figuring out what this story can handle and what the audience is willing to accept.
所以你在摸索这个故事能承载什么，观众愿意接受什么。
Totally.
完全正确。
And we had an aired when we shot this episode, right?
我们拍这集的时候还没播出吧，对吧？
No.
没有。
We would not have aired.
还没播过。
Yeah, we were good.
对，我们状态不错。
So we really didn't know.
所以我们其实一无所知。
Like we were inventing this world and hoping that it landed.
我们就像是在创造这个世界，并祈祷它能取得反响。
I have to say though, one of my all-time favorite, how I met your mother, Gags, is breaking up on the answer machine.
不过我得说，《老爸老妈浪漫史》里我最喜欢的名场面之一，就是通过电话留言分手。
Oh my God.
天哪。
Well, people are gathered for a surprise party.
好吧，当时大家正聚在一起开惊喜派对。
Is unbelievable.
这简直难以置信。
I forgot.
我都忘了。
I'm not kidding, Corny.
我没开玩笑，科妮。
Did you have any moments like this when you were watching it?
你重温的时候有没有过这种时刻？
And I'm almost sad to admit this, but I forgot that there was the widening out that we read.
我甚至有点不好意思承认，但我忘了我们当时还写了镜头拉远的那一幕。
you saw the answering machine and then there's this other horrific reveal that makes it so much worse.
你先是看到录音电话，接着又有一个更可怕的转折，让情况变得更糟。
I sort of forgot about that second reveal.
我差不多把第二个转折给忘光了。
I don't know what happened in my brain, but I was like, I really, it really hit me.
我不知道我的脑子怎么了，但我当时就觉得，真的，深深地触动了我。
And I was, I was, it was hilarious.
而且我当时觉得，这太爆笑了。
And it was also like, God, dead.
同时心里又在想，天哪，泰德。
What were you doing, man?
老兄，你当时在干什么呢？
It was like, it's also, it's also, but you're, you're missing a joke.
就好像，这也是，这也是，但你漏了一个笑点。
It's three jokes, right?
其实是三个笑点，对吧？
Because first, it's just the answering machine.
因为首先，只是录音电话。
Then it's pulled out, oh, you think everyone's listening.
然后镜头拉开，哦，你以为每个人都在听。
And then no, she's not even there.
接着不，她甚至不在那儿。
She has to come into the surprise reveal.
她不得不走进来，形成了一个惊喜反转。
It's a triple reveal.
这是一个三重反转。
Yeah.
对。
Was there anything when you rewatched it that you didn't remember and it caught you?
你重温的时候，有没有什么情节是你完全不记得了，然后把你惊艳到了？
I just, I forgot about the triple reveal, I guess is exact as a way to say it.
我只是，我把那个三重反转给忘了，这么说大概最准确吧。
Yeah.
对。
I totally forgot about the triple reveal, like it was the same thing for me.
我完全把三重反转给忘了，我的感觉一模一样。
I was like, oh, that's funny.
我当时想，哦，太搞笑了。
That's good.
太棒了。
That was a good job.
那一幕处理得真好。
That's weird.
真奇怪。
We were good.
我们当时拍得真好。
I really did enjoy that.
我真的很享受那个部分。
The other thing that was sort of funny was, I sort of forgot the Robin Barney story in it.
还有一件事挺有意思的，我差不多把里面罗宾和巴尼的故事线给忘了。
Sometimes in my head, I don't match the right A-Stories with B-Stories.
有时候在我的脑海里，我没把正确的主线和副线对应起来。
Do you know what I mean?
你知道我的意思吗？
So when I saw it, I was like, all right, this.
所以当我看到它时，我就想，好吧，原来是这样。
And it's interesting because I remember in the breaking of it, in the early moments of the show, I think one of the characters we were really still trying to figure out was Robin.
这很有趣，因为我记得在创作它的时候，在剧集刚开始的阶段，我觉得我们真正还在摸索的角色之一其实是罗宾。
Because it was like Ted loves Robin And she like, how do we make her after it?
因为当时的情况是，泰德爱着罗宾，而她——我们该如何让她出彩？
How do we make her interesting?
我们如何让她的形象变得有趣？
How do we all these things?
我们如何处理所有这些事情？
And I remember I was worried that the like, she's doing this shit on air.
我记得我当时很担心，就像她这样在节目里搞这些破事。
Like, will the audience disconnect from her?
观众会不会对她产生疏离感？
We thought she was like this career woman, but she doesn't give a shit.
我们本以为她是个职业女性，但她却根本不在乎。
And Kobe plays that all so well that she's sort of like, drawn to the dark side and there's like more to her.
而科比把这个角色演得太好了，她仿佛是被黑暗面吸引了过去，这个角色身上还有更多的层次。
And I feel like it was sort of like, one of the first steps towards, you know, Robin became such a fun character to write and Kobe, what she did with it was always so amazing.
我觉得这就像是，朝着那个方向迈出的第一步，你知道的，罗宾后来成了写起来非常有趣的角色的，而科比对这个角色的演绎总是那么惊艳。
And I feel like this was one of the steps zones along the way that you're like, oh, this girl's weird.
我觉得这是沿途的里程碑之一，你会觉得，哦，这姑娘挺怪的。
This girl's got some like shit going on.
这姑娘身上有点不可告人的秘密。
Like what's going on with her?
她到底怎么了？
You know, it's the first, I think it's the first one because we've now, we've done, this is our fourth episode we're doing on the podcast about.
你知道的，这是第一集，我觉得这是第一部，因为我们现在已经做了，这是我们在播客里做的关于这部剧的第四集。
And this is the first one where she is purely in a comedy story.
而这是她纯粹参与喜剧故事的第一集。
You know what I mean?
你知道我的意思吗？
She has other things to do.
她还有别的事要做。
She kind of, in episode three, sweet taste of liberty, she's kind of there in a way to serve as Lily's story.
在某种程度上，在第三集《自由的甜蜜滋味》里，她出现的作用有点像是为莉莉的故事服务。
Lily's thing about, she has her ring and she feels like she's noticed in the bar anymore.
莉莉的事是，她戴着戒指，觉得自己不再受酒吧里的人关注了。
And she sort of support it.
而罗宾算是在一旁支持她。
And then the first two episodes, which we keep saying feels like an hour long episode, the first two episodes, the pilot and purple giraffe really are almost like an hour.
然后前两集，我们总说感觉像一小时长的一集，前两集，试播集和紫色长颈鹿，真的差不多有一小时长。
She's the sought after object and she's the romantic comedy, like heroin, the female lead.
她是那个被追求的对象，她是浪漫喜剧里的女主角。
This is the first time she gets to be funny.
这是她第一次有机会变得搞笑。
And I think that's a really interesting point like it's a good way to frame it.
我觉得这是一个非常有趣的观点，这真是一个很好的切入点。
This is this is the first time we really figured out she can just be in a comedy story.
这是我们第一次真正发现她可以单纯地融入一个喜剧故事中。
She said I think there was and that story.
我觉得当时有，而且那个故事。
It was also like you guys, it was the first time you were really mining her job for pure laughs.
这也是你们第一次真正利用她的工作来制造纯粹的笑料。
Yeah.
对。
And there's something so this is going to sound like such a weird comparison but Kobe's ability to like speak as a newscaster or like a reporter, like a metro reporter was it just came to her so easily.
而且那种感觉——这听起来可能是一个很奇怪的类比——但科比模仿新闻主播或记者说话的能力，比如都市记者的那种语气，对她来说简直轻而易举。
It reminded me of this this is such a weird comparison, but Julianne Moore and Boogie Knight's, like her porn acting is so genius.
这让我想起了——这真是一个奇怪的类比——朱丽安·摩尔在《不羁夜》里的表现，她演色情片演员简直是个天才。
Like there's a kind of culture of there's newscaster speak, right?
就好像有一种所谓的“新闻主播腔”，对吧？
Have you ever seen that there's that woman on like TikTok or Instagram like who does like she narrates her family stuff through like the like a newscaster voice?
你见过那种在TikTok或Instagram上的女人吗，她用类似新闻主播的语调来讲述她家里的日常？
Oh nice.
哦，有意思。
But Kobe just I always found, and especially when we introduced Sandy Rivers, Like there was so much good comedy on, what was it called Wake Up New York, or what was the early morning?
但科比就是——我一直觉得，尤其是当我们引入桑迪·里弗斯这个角色的时候，关于那个节目——叫什么来着，《纽约早安》还是什么的清晨节目——有很多非常棒的喜剧效果。
Oh my God, what was it called?
天哪，那叫什么来着？
Get up New York, something like that.
《起床吧纽约》，差不多这名字。
Oh my God.
天哪。
I can't remember.
我想不起来了。
Yeah, it was really aggressive.
对，真的很有侵略性。
It was like an aggressive title.
就好像是个很有攻击性的标题。
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
对，对，对。
But I thought that was a fun, comedic well, to go back to over the years of Kobe at work, or Robin at work, and how, yeah, just like how no one was quite watched, How it was like this glamorous job, but it was also not glamorous, really.
但我觉得这是一个挺有意思、挺有喜剧效果的梗，在接下来的几年里可以不断回味，比如在工作中科比，或者在工作中罗宾，然后，对，就像那种根本没人看的感觉，虽然这工作听起来光鲜亮丽，但实际上一点也不光鲜。
Yeah.
对。
And it's the moment she realizes no one watches this.
这就是她意识到根本没人看这个节目的那一刻。
Even her boss at the station doesn't watch the.
甚至她在电视台的老板都不看这个。
Yeah.
对。
Shout out to Janet Kagan's husband.
向珍妮特·卡agan的丈夫致敬。
Janet Kagan, our script supervisor, her husband is great as that guy.
珍妮特·卡agan，我们的剧本总监，她丈夫演那个角色演得太棒了。
Yeah.
对。
And it's the other thing we discovered in that episode in addition to just how funny Koby is.
还有我们在那一集中发现的另一件事，除了科比本身有多搞笑之外。
And when you give her a straight up comedy story, her physical comedy's funny.
当给她一个纯粹的喜剧桥段时，她的肢体喜剧太逗了。
That's all that she does.
她做的全都是这些。
That's all is great.
全都很棒。
Spanking her butt with like dead eyes was hilarious.
她面无表情地拍打自己的屁股，简直太搞笑了。
Like completely dead inside spanking her, but because life has lost all meaning because no one watches what she does.
就像内心已经彻底死寂一样拍打自己的屁股，因为生活已经失去了所有意义，因为没有人看她做节目。
And this is her finding that out.
而这就是她发现这一事实的时刻。
When she falls, that is a funny, I was watching with her back.
当她摔倒的时候，那太搞笑了，我是和她背靠背看的。
She hadn't watched that episode since an era, I think.
我想她已经很久没看那一集了。
And she was, she lost her mind laughing my wife at that fall Kobe takes.
结果她笑疯了，我妻子看到科比那个摔倒时。
It's also, it's also, it restores Barney as a literal devil.
而且这也，这也让巴尼重新回到了字面意义上的恶魔形象。
Like he's, we talked a lot about how like Barney's like the devil, he's the temper of this series.
就像我们经常讨论的那样，巴尼就像个恶魔，他是这部剧里的魔鬼。
And he's literally just like cackling and handing out brides and like coming up with ever more devious schemes.
他简直就是在狂笑、派发贿赂，想出越来越阴险的计谋。
And he's, I mean, he's a bit of, he's the joker like he just wants to create chaos.
我的意思是，他有点像小丑，他只想制造混乱。
He just wants to, yeah, he worships, he just wants to see it all burn down.
他只想，对，他崇拜混乱，他只想看着这一切化为灰烬。
You know what else really made me laugh?
你知道还有什么真的让我笑出来吗？
It was such a small thing.
那只是一个很小的细节。
But this is just a shout out to Ali Hannigan.
但这要向艾莉·汉尼根致敬。
Her laugh when she like makes herself laugh over the word booger is so honest, so natural.
她因为“鼻屎”这个词而自娱自乐的笑声，是那么真诚，那么自然。
Like Ali, Ali really has that thing of like as if it's for the first time, like she's able to do that thing that is, is basically the basics of good acting, but she does it so consistently.
就像艾莉，艾莉真的有一种能力，就像是第一次发生那样，她能够做到那种基本上是优秀表演基础的事情，但她做得非常稳定。
So naturally.
非常自然。
And she, I just felt like she really surprised herself with that.
而且她，我只是觉得她真的被那个词逗乐了，连她自己都始料未及。
I was delighted by it.
我对此感到非常高兴。
Her laughing at booger was one of my favorite moments in the whole episode.
她听到“鼻屎”就笑出声，是我整集中最喜欢的时刻之一。
it's right at the beginning and she just has this very, you're right.
就在开头，她有那种很——你说得对。
It's a little throwaway, but it's so charming.
那只是个随性的小包袱，但太迷人了。
It's funny because it's thrown away.
好笑就因为它是随性抛出来的。
Yeah.
对。
The icky shuffle Courtney, was that you?
那个“恶心舞”（icky shuffle），考特尼，那是你吗？
Was that you?
那是你吗？
Was that, was that a shout out to your husband?
那是，那是向你丈夫致敬吗？
I'm trying to think of where the hell we got the icky shuffle from.
我在努力想我们到底从哪弄来的这个“恶心舞”。
Yeah, I think like definitely I'm always trying to squeeze dancing into more dancing into things.
对，我觉得我肯定一直在试图在节目里塞进更多的舞蹈。
And so I think that did come from, I think the, yes, I want to say that was me, but if there's a higher out there that's out there like, like, fuck you, that was me, I apologize.
所以我觉得那确实是，我觉得，是的，我想说那是我想出来的，但如果有更高的存在想说“操，那是我想的”，我道歉。
This is a great glimpse into writer's minds.
这真是窥探编剧内心世界的好机会。
You can't even take credit for one thing in this episode.
你在这集里连一件事都不敢居功。
You wrote this episode, you can say it.
这集是你写的，你可以承认。
I did, I did.
是我写的，确实是我写的。
A lot of it to you.
很大一部分功劳归你。
Yeah, no, I think that might have been me, but yeah, it's funny.
对，不，我觉得那可能确实是我写的，不过这挺搞笑的。
I might rewatch to the other really fun thing I thought about the Rob and Barney story is exactly like you're saying how he's the Joker.
我可能会再看一遍，关于罗宾和巴尼的故事，另一个我觉得非常有趣的点就像你说的，他就像是小丑。
He, it sort of sets him up as the Devil and Lily, it sort of really solidifies her as like the angel on your shoulder, like trying to do good, wanting to, you know, in terms of like the dynamics of the show and like what everyone's bringing to the group, you know, I think it's a really nice, you know, and I feel like it's interesting, like it sort of sets up the, like, Barney, Robin have this dark side that they are in due.
他有点像把他塑造成恶魔，而莉莉则真正巩固了她作为你肩头天使的形象，就像是试图做好事，想要，你知道的，就节目的动态以及每个人给团队带来的东西而言，你知道的，我觉得这是一个非常好的，你知道的，而且我觉得很有趣，就像它有点建立了巴尼和罗宾有这样黑暗的一面，他们在其中。
Like it sort of started the bond between them a little bit, you know, that ultimately obviously grew in series.
就像它在某种程度上开始了一点他们之间的纽带，你知道的，这在后来的剧集里显然发展了。
But yeah, that storyline was, there was a surprise for me.
但是，是的，那条故事线对我来说是个惊喜。
I was like, oh, yeah, this is huge, you know what I mean?
我当时想，哦，是的，这太重要了，你知道我的意思吗？
It's like the DNA is like you see where it was kind of planted in.
就像基因一样，你能看出它是种在哪里。
It's not just martial Ted.
不仅仅是马修和泰德。
It's like martial Ted Lily, like and how invested Lily and Ted are, are Lily and martial are in making sure they have that like back porch fantasy together with the, the four, they want to get, they want to complete the quartet for Ted.
就像马修、泰德、莉莉，以及莉莉和泰德、莉莉和马修对确保他们能和那四个人一起实现后廊幻想有多投入，他们想要，他们想为泰德凑齐四人组。
And she also wants him to do it, you know, her hitting him like 27 times in the episode.
而且她还希望他做到，你知道的，她在这一集里打了她大概27次。
Like she wants him to do it well.
就像她希望他做好一样。
She wants him to be a mench.
她希望他成为一个有担当的人。
She wants him to like not, she wants him to be one of the good guys.
她希望他不要，她希望他是好人之一。
I could just shout out as we're thinking about this.
我想在我们思考这个问题的时候大声感谢一下。
I want to call to Hannah Wells, who asks exactly this question.
我要感谢汉娜·韦尔斯，她问的正是这个问题。
And it goes to also Courtney, as you as the writer, I think I I think people are probably curious about this notion of you being the writer of an episode.
这也关乎考特尼，作为编剧的你，我想大家可能会对你作为一集编剧的这个概念感到好奇。
This is the first time that we're talking about something like this where a story is broken in the room and then you go and write it but how does that connect to the other 10 writers that there are?
这是我们第一次讨论这样的事情，一个故事在编剧室里构思出来，然后你去写它，但这与另外10个编剧有什么联系呢？
And she asks, was Lily always supposed to be Ted's greatest teacher in love or does that spark happen in this episode?
她问，莉莉一直被设定为泰德在爱情上最伟大的导师，还是这个火花是在这一集里产生的？
So can you talk about what your job is as the writer as compared to what the room is doing and what you're inventing versus what they're inventing.
所以你能谈谈你作为编剧的工作与编剧室在做什么相比是怎样的吗，以及什么是你发明的，什么是他们发明的。
And this question about who came up with this idea of what that relationship would be between Lily and Ted?
关于莉莉和泰德之间那种关系是谁想出来的这个问题？
Yeah, I mean, Craig, jump in too.
对，我的意思是，克雷格，你也来说说。
It's a writer of an episode can mean so many different things on different shows.
在不同的节目中，一集剧本的编剧可以意味着很多不同的事情。
And in different instances, it means something different.
在不同的情况下，它的含义也不同。
I feel like in this specific instance, the way I think what was so great about the way how I met your mother broke your stories, broke stories in the way that Carter and Craig led the room is it always started from like, here's a real thing that happens to me or here's something I noticed or here's something about relationships and people would jump in and go, oh my God, that happened to me.
我觉得在这个具体情况下，《老爸老妈浪漫史》构思故事的方式最棒的地方在于——卡特和克雷格领导编剧室的方式是，它总是从这样一个起点开始：“这里有一件发生在我身上的真实事情”或者“这里有些我注意到的事情”或者“关于人际关系的一些事情”，然后大家会加入并说：“天哪，我也遇到过那种事。”
And so if I had to guess, my guess was we started talking about like, it's hard to break up with people and everybody shared their stories of things they done and it's like, oh my God, what if Ted has to do that?
所以如果要我猜的话，我猜我们当时开始讨论的是：“跟别人分手太难了”，然后每个人都分享了自己做过的事的故事，接着就像是：“天哪，如果泰德不得不这么做会怎么样？”
Oh my God, then what if it's his birthday, you know, and what if it's these things And it's sort of like, you know, it kind of grows.
“天哪，那如果是他的生日呢，你知道的，如果再加上这些事情会怎么样？”事情就是这样，你知道的，它慢慢发展起来了。
And that's when a room is fantastic, there's nothing more fun than like pitching on it all together.
当一个编剧室状态极佳时，没有什么比大家一起集思广益更有趣的了。
And then essentially, you know, we sort of go, okay, we have this idea.
然后基本上，你知道的，我们会说，好吧，我们有这个主意了。
And then you put it up on a dry erase board and you beat out, you know, the beats of the story of what it can be.
接着你把它写在白板上，然后梳理出，你知道的，故事的节拍以及它可能会呈现的样子。
And then the writer, I would go off and like put it in an outline and like a word document.
然后作为编剧，我会离开，把它写成大纲，放进Word文档里。
It's like, okay, this scene, this scene.
就像是，好吧，这场戏，那场戏。
Oh, here's a funny joke here, here's a funny joke there.
哦，这里有个好笑的笑话，那里有个好笑的笑话。
And then they would come back in the room and everybody would pitch on it, have thoughts and Carter and Craig would really sort of lead, you know, where the ship is going.
然后他们会回到房间里，每个人都会提出建议、发表想法，而卡特和克雷格会真正地引领方向，你知道的，指明这艘船要开往哪里。
And I think, you know, you guys were great showrunners in that I think they had a really clear North Star of the story they wanted to tell.
而且我认为，你知道的，你们俩是伟大的剧集运作人，因为我觉得他们对于想要讲述的故事有着非常清晰的北极星指引。
And then as a writer, it's your job to pitch on how we can get there.
然后作为编剧，你的工作就是提出关于我们如何到达那里的建议。
Like this is, I'll row this way.
就像这样：我往这边划桨。
You row that way and then we'll, you know what I mean?
你往那边划，然后我们，你知道我的意思吗？
We all knew where we were going, like there was a certain tone to the show, like it was really funny, but it was very grounded and had heart.
我们都知道我们要去哪里，节目有一种特定的基调，比如它非常搞笑，但又非常贴近现实且走心。
And so then you go off and you write the episode and then you bring it back again into the room and people pitch on it.
所以接着你去写剧本，然后把它再次带回房间里，大家会对它提出意见。
And it's interesting because a lot of times stories will change from, you know, things will change from a writer's draft, but Rob Greenberg who, you know, I used to call him Puppup because he was so much older and I'd since discovered I'm like now like 10 years older than he ever he was so young.
这很有趣，因为很多时候故事会发生变化，你知道的，有些东西会从编剧的初稿中改变，但罗伯·格林伯格——你知道的，我以前叫他“Puppup”，因为他比我大很多，后来我才发现，我现在比他当时大差不多10岁，他当时太年轻了。
He was an old guy at like 39 or whatever the fuck yeah.
他大概39岁或者管他妈的几岁时就老气横秋的了，对。
I'm sorry but I remember he once said if you write a script and every line every joke changes but the story is the same and you made the story work like that's a good draft you know because sometimes his writer is there's like a joke you love or a moment that sometimes changes for one reason or another it ultimately doesn't serve the character where we want to go.
不好意思，但我记得他曾经说过，如果你写了一个剧本，每一行台词、每一个笑话都变了，但故事本身没变，而且你把故事理顺了，那这就是一个好剧本，你知道的，因为有时作为编剧，会有你喜爱的笑话或某个时刻，由于这样或那样的原因最终改变了，它最终没能为主线人物服务，也没能带我们去到想去的地方。
And so yeah, so I went off and wrote this script and fun fact, this is the first TV script I wrote that actually made it to the air.
所以，是的，我当时去写了这个剧本，有趣的事实是，这是我写的第一个真正播出了的电视剧剧本。
Oh my gosh.
哦，天哪。
Yes, I had written other ones that the show has all got canceled before.
是的，我以前写过其他剧集，但都在播出前被砍了。
I was always like episode like three or four and then it was like, you know, got like two and out or something.
我总是写到第三集或第四集左右，然后就，你知道的，播了两集就被砍了或者别的什么。
And so So this was a very big, this was a very big deal for me.
所以这对我和来说是一件非常非常重要的大事。
You did not advertise that fact when we hired you, that you read episodes of Shadows and they get canceled before the air.
我们雇你的时候，你可没说你写的《老爸老妈的浪漫史》剧集在播出前都会被砍。
We might have thought twice, but you know, you should have told us Courtney one of the things.
我们本来可能会三思的，但你知道的，考特尼，你本来应该告诉我们的。
One of the things we're exploring on this show is why this show inspires so much fervor and why is it so beloved and why do people watch it over and over and why do people watch it when they're going through a really hard time in their lives.
我们在本节目中探讨的事情之一，就是为什么这部剧能激起如此巨大的狂热，为什么它如此备受喜爱，为什么人们会一遍又一遍地观看，以及为什么当人们生活中经历非常艰难的时刻时会选择看它。
there's all these kind of like mysteries at the heart of what has made this show so durable.
在这部剧经久不衰的内核中，存在着各种各样的神秘之处。
And I think you're hitting on something which is there would be no story that was pitched or accepted to kind of be turned into a draft unless it was grounded in something real.
我想你点出了关键所在，那就是如果没有立足于现实的东西，就不会有任何被构思或接受并最终写成初稿的故事。
So I think when even if the story could spin off into Bonkers land and it was lit really brightly on a sound stage in Hollywood and in LA and there was laughter coming through, that was piped in, it still had this feeling that like I know these people or this happened to me.
所以我觉得，即使这个故事可能会变得无比疯狂，而且是在好莱坞和洛杉矶的摄影棚里被强烈的光线照亮，还有罐头笑声传来，它依然给人一种“我认识这些人”或“这事也发生在我身上”的感觉。
And I think that's what that's what that's what a lot of what people resonate with.
我想这就是引起很多人共鸣的地方。
And I'll give Courtney a lot.
我得给考特尼记大功。
Courtney, one thing I love about you, I love many things about you, but you were always so good at bringing in real life stuff and bringing in like the basic raw material that could then lead to the story having that feeling.
考特尼，我喜欢你的一点——我喜欢你身上的很多优点——但你总是擅长引入现实生活中的元素，引入那些最基础的素材，从而让故事拥有乔什刚刚所描述的那种感觉。
Josh just described.
乔什刚刚描述的。
Just starting with something real, starting with like it's hard to break up with people.
就是从真实的事情开始，比如和别人分手很难。
It's hard to be broken up with.
被人甩了很难。
It's hard to to break up with people, starting with that idea of like how finding a thing can kind of unlock a portal to the past, right?
和别人分手很难，从这个想法切入：寻找一件东西如何能开启通往过去的大门，对吧？
He finds a shirt and somehow the Rube Goldberg machine gets created from that point.
他找到了一件衬衫，然后鲁伯特·戈德堡机械效应就从那一刻开始了。
And from that point, you say the shirt leads back to this girl, leads back to this whole sorted tale of how he broke up with her, leads to him getting back into her life and breaking up with her again, also on her birthday in the worst way possible and culminating in tagging and she had kicked out of them.
从那一刻起，正如你所说，这件衬衫把线索引向了这个女孩，引向了他如何与她分手的整段复杂故事，引得他重新回到她的生活并再次甩了她，而且还是在她生日那天，用最糟糕的方式，最终导致了……她把他们赶了出去。
That shot, it's in slow motion of the PO Ted's POV, as easy as he could be.
那个镜头，泰德视角下的慢动作，要多狼狈有多狼狈。
Oh my God.
天哪。
I forgot that.
我都忘。
我都忘了。
And she was so hilarious.
她当时太搞笑了。
Yeah.
对。
Shout out to any dude at.
向安妮·达德利致敬。
Any dude at.
安妮·达德利。
Yes.
是的。
She did so good.
她演得太棒了。
She and I ended up becoming really good friends.
我和她最后成了非常要好的朋友。
Like, a lot of people don't, like, these people, you're just on stage 22 and all these incredible actors and dynamic person, they come to the set and you, some of them you really take with you.
比如，很多人不知道，这些人，你只是在22号摄影棚里，面对所有这些优秀的演员和充满活力的人，他们来到片场，而你，有些人真的会一直留在你心中。
just hi Annie if you're listening.
只是打个招呼，安妮，如果你在听的话。她在那一集里演得太棒了。
She was so good on that episode.
太棒了。
Perfect.
完美。
And so I don't know she was so, she looked like strong and confident and completely woundable all at the same time.
所以我不知道，她看起来既坚强自信，又同时完全脆弱不堪。
Yeah, her fragility and her like, I can't believe I let myself, this happened to me again.
对，她的脆弱以及那种“我怎么会让自己陷入这种境地，这种事怎么又发生在我身上”的感觉。
I love the flashbacks to like when he's going through like, oh whatever happened to so and so whatever happened so and so I always loved when Ted could be like a silent film star like when he could just like drop a meatball and like have a you know one of my luck.
我喜欢那些闪回镜头，比如当他在经历“哦，某某某后来怎么了，某某某后来怎么了”，我一直都很喜欢泰德能像个默片明星一样的时候，比如他可以随手掉下一个肉丸，然后来一个……你知道的。
And that final scene between the two of us at that restaurant I think is just so funny.
我和你在那家餐厅的最后一场戏，我觉得实在是太搞笑了。
I did have this thought when I saw the shirt, I was like why didn't I button one more button?
当我看到那件衬衫时，我确实有过这样的想法：我当时怎么没多扣一个扣子？
Like it looked like two and I remember I think the costume designer and I had a conversation Okay, we're going to not button that one, but when you go out to dinner, you're going to button the one, uh, because it's fancy, you know, now it's fancy.
看起来好像解开了两颗，我记得我和服装设计师聊过，好吧，我们本来不打算扣那一颗，但当你出去吃晚饭时，你要把那一颗扣上，呃，因为这样比较正式，你知道的，现在这样比较正式。
Right.
对。
So how many days is Ted Berryman churning around?
所以泰德·贝里曼穿着这件衬衫转悠了多少天？
Yeah, it's seriously.
对，说真的。
He really, he really works it for that whole week.
整整一个星期他都穿着这件衬衫。
Or however long they're together.
或者不管他们在一起多久。
I mean, that's kind of the part of the funny, like, non-reality of it is he never takes off the shirt.
我的意思是，这正是那种搞笑的、不切实际的部分，他从来不脱这件衬衫。
It's ridiculous.
太荒谬了。
But I loved, uh, I loved your awesome.
但我喜欢，呃，我喜欢你们那个精彩的梗。
Like, I loved that runner.
就像，我喜欢那个贯穿始终的梗。
So funny.
太搞笑了。
It's really funny.
真的太搞笑了。
You play that print.
你播放那个段落。
I think ineffable is one of the great how I met your mother jokes.
我觉得“不可言喻”是《老爸老妈浪漫史》里最棒的笑话之一。
I'm not I'm not affable.
我不是，我不是平易近人。
That's a Craig Thomas Joe Craig Thomas.
那是克雷格·托马斯的笑话，克雷格·托马斯。
I remember when he pitched that it with the room like lost it.
我记得他提出这个点子时，整个房间的人都笑疯了。
That was so good.
太棒了。
So good.
I'm not going to be modest.
我不会假装谦虚。
I'm going to say yes.
我要说，是的。
That was mine.
那是我的。
That was a great joke.
那是个绝妙的笑话。
Courtney is like a good person.
考特尼就像是个好人。
She's like I'm not sure I'm like that's mine.
她好像在说，我不确定，我就觉得那是我的。
And this old man.
还有这个老头。
He We must did me, fell in love with you, knew you were a city.
他……我们一定……爱上了你，知道你是个大都市。
And now, commercials!
好了，广告时间！
Hi, I'm Alex Goldman, host of the HyperFixed podcast.
嗨，我是亚历克斯·戈德曼，《HyperFixed》播客的主持人。
Each week, we take listeners' problems and try to solve them for them.
每周，我们都会收集听众的烦恼并试着为他们解决。
Problems like, I'm 30 and I'm scared to drive in New York.
比如这样的问题：我30岁了，却不敢在纽约开车。
Or, why can't I adjust the volume of my car stereo when I'm in reverse?
或者，为什么我倒车时不能调节汽车音响的音量？
We also solve non-car related problems.
我们也解决非汽车相关的问题。
If you have a problem, not only will we fix it, we'll expose the hidden systems that cause that problem in the first place.
如果你有什么问题，我们不仅会帮你解决，还会揭露导致该问题的背后隐藏系统。
That's the HyperFixed podcast from Radio Topia.
这就是来自 Radio Topia 的《HyperFixed》播客。
Find it wherever you find podcasts, or at HyperFixedPod.com.
在各大播客平台或访问 HyperFixedPod.com 即可收听。
End of commercials back to show.
广告结束，回到节目。
I love the lather that Ted gets worked into trying to be a good guy and he can't get out of this.
我喜欢泰德为了装好人而急得焦头烂额的样子，而且他根本摆脱不了。
And it's her birthday and he doesn't want to do it.
今天是她的生日，他其实根本不想去。
And he knows he has to do it.
但他知道自己必须去。
And just ending with, I'm just like super busy right now.
结果最后以一句“我最近真的超级忙”收场。
Love that, I like that.
太棒了，我喜欢这个。
Really made me laugh.
真的把我逗笑了。
And by the time he gets kicked by her, you're kind of like just put him out of his misery, like just end this thing.
等他被她一脚踢开的时候，你简直会觉得，给他个痛快吧，赶紧结束这段关系吧。
Like it's really brutal.
真的太残忍了。
By the way, I think you couldn't, you couldn't on CVS say, go F yourself or say F to mean the F word, but that's why in F of all was really delightful.
顺便说一句，我觉得在CBS电视台，你不能说“去你的”或者用F开头来指那个F打头的词，但这就是为什么“不可言喻（Ineffable）”那么令人高兴。
I was really worried it was gonna get knocked out because it kind of is saying F of all, but because we headed within an actual word we got it, and that was, I remember taking great joy.
我当时真的很担心这个词会被砍掉，因为它听起来有点像在说F打头的词，但因为它包含在一个真正的词里面，我们通过了，我记得当时感到无比快乐。
It's the fact that we sort of like flew under the sensor's radar.
就因为我们有点像是在躲避审查员的雷达。
Is it really this word?
真的是这个词吗？
It's like the Hollywood code in the four years.
这就像是四五十年代的好莱坞审查制度。
like you had to, you had to smuggle stuff in.
就像你必须得，必须得把东西偷偷塞进去。
Yeah.
对。
Really?
真的吗？
I do.
是的。
Yeah.
对。
Go ahead.
你接着说。
No, I was going to say, I do remember that quick.
不，我是想说，我确实记得那个笑话。
Because like, you would get the memo of the, like, standards and practices.
因为你会收到审查标准和规范部门的备忘录。
Oh, yeah.
哦，对。
We were so nervous.
我们当时紧张极了。
And I remember, I was like running.
我记得，我当时就像是在……
It was like, Christmas morning.
就像是圣诞节的早晨。
Did you dig in?
你开动了吗？
Yeah.
是的。
It's a word.
这倒是个词。
It's really over.
真的结束了。
Yeah.
对。
And it's set up early in the episode in an organic way.
而且它在剧集前期就以一种很自然的方式铺垫好了。
And it comes back around.
然后它又呼应上了。
Yeah.
对。
So we were clever on that one.
所以我们在那一集里写得很巧妙。
I also remember getting the spaghetti thrown at me.
我也记得当时有人把意大利面朝我身上扔。
And, you know, the crew delighted in that.
而且，你知道，剧组人员对此乐此不疲。
I remember that, but also having props and costume come on and trying to drape, like, they're trying to recreate the first taste and they have to like recreate the pasta splatter on me.
我还记得那件事，当时道具和服装组上来，试图摆造型，他们想重现那种最初的滋味，必须得把意大利面的溅痕重新弄到我身上。
In those moments, you're like, what's my job?
在那样的时刻，你会想，我的工作到底是什么？
How am I getting paid?
我这钱是怎么赚来的？
People are placing pasta on my body and that's my job today.
人们把意大利面往我身上摆，这就是我今天的工作。
Yeah.
对。
That's a weird job.
真是个奇怪的工作。
It's a living.
这也是谋生嘛。
Courtney, and like, even the Robin story.
考妮，还有，甚至连罗宾的故事也是。
I feel like the thing you just said about you were working on shows, you'd write the episodes.
我觉得你刚才说的，你以前在剧组工作时，会亲自写剧本。
I think you even got episodes produced and shot.
我想你甚至还有剧集被制作并拍摄出来了。
I'm remembering this whole story now.
我现在把整个故事都想起来了。
And then the show would get canceled before it would air, right?
然后节目还没播就惨遭腰斩了，对吧？
I feel like even in the Robin story, you were channeling something.
我觉得甚至在罗宾的故事里，你也在传达某种情绪。
That idea of like, I'm doing something no one sees.
那种“我在做一件没人看得到的事”的想法。
Like you experienced that in your actual writing life.
就像你在实际的编剧生涯中经历过的那样。
And I always feel like there was something you always found a way to get like some of your yourself and your life and some like truths in there.
我总觉得，你总是能找到某种方式，把你自己、你的生活以及某些真实的东西融入其中。
And then again, you build this big Rube Goldberg machine with the writer's room after that.
然后，接下来你又和编剧室一起打造了这台巨大的“鲁布·戈德堡机械”。
And you say, what's the worst way Ted could break up with this girl?
你问：泰德跟这个女孩分手的最糟糕方式是什么？
What's the steepest climb to get back in the girl's life?
重新回到这个女孩的生活中，最艰难的爬坡路是什么？
That's how you get to the triple reveal joke about it's an answering machine.
这就是你们如何构思出那个三重反转的笑话：这是一个答录机。
It's a surprise party.
这是一个惊喜派对。
Ted will always be the guy that broke up with her in an answering machine during her surprise party.
泰德永远会是那个在她惊喜派对期间用答录机跟她分手的家伙。
And we constructed that elaborate thing to create this steep hell for Ted to climb.
我们构建了那个精心设计的情节，为泰德创造了这个需要艰难跨越的地狱。
But it doesn't start there.
但它并不是从那儿开始的。
It starts from like, let's do an episode about just how hard it is to break up with someone.
它是从这样一个想法开始的：让我们拍一集关于跟别人分手有多难的剧吧。
And then what's the worst way we can imagine that?
然后，我们能想到的最糟糕的方式是什么？
And he has to clear that hurdle and then break up with her again.
而他必须跨过那个障碍，然后再跟她分手一次。
So it's like where I feel like, now I made your mother was marrying two worlds.
所以这就好像，我觉得《老爸老妈浪漫史》融合了两个世界。
It was marrying this like truthful, like more like indie film world with a sitcom.
它把这种真实感、更偏向独立电影的世界与情景喜剧结合在了一起。
Cause you have this incredibly truthful thing, but then you spin it into this like comedic kind of Sunday, right?
因为你拥有这种极其真实的东西，但随后你又把它卷入这种喜剧式的狂欢中，对吧？
Like where you're just like, it's insane.
就好像你会觉得，这太疯狂了。
You couldn't, you couldn't quite get away with this in a movie.
你在电影里根本无法蒙混过关。
I mean, maybe like a broad comedy or something, but it really, it really keeps it grounded in like sitcom land, but also grounded in this other truthful space that I think how my mother was like really pioneering around.
我是说，也许在某种通俗喜剧里可以，但它真正让它既扎根于情景喜剧的土地上，又扎根于另一个真实的领域，我认为这是《老爸老妈浪漫史》真正开创性的地方。
Yes.
是的。
And I think the, I think quite what you're remembering.
而且我认为，我想你记得的完全没错。
So I had been on these shows that all got canceled.
我以前参与过的那些剧集最后都被砍了。
And I had recently gone to my 10 year high school reunion, and people were like, what do you do?
我最近去参加了高中毕业十周年同学会，大家都在问：“你是做什么的？”
And I was like, I'm a TV writer.
我说：“我是一个电视编剧。”
And they were like, well, like shows do you write on?
然后他们就问：“哦，你写过哪些剧？”
And I go, oh, they haven't made it to me.
我说：“哦，它们还没播呢。”
And they don't exist theoretical shows.
那些是不存在的理论上的剧集。
You'll never see it.
你们永远也看不到。
Yeah, they were like, what do you mean?
对，他们就问：“什么意思？”
I'm like, well, it happens all the time.
我说：“嗯，这种事经常发生。”
Like networks, like this was, you know, post must see TV.
就像各大电视台，你知道的，这是“必看电视”之后的时代。
Like there are money's going everywhere.
到处都是资金在流动。
And I was like, well, you can make shows and then you make episodes, but then they don't air.
我说，你可以制作节目，也可以拍出剧集，但它们就是不播。
And so like literally people in my high school were hearing them were like, so you make TV shows, but they're not on TV.
所以，我高中的人听到这些时，字面意思就是：所以你制作电视节目，但它们不上电视。
It was literally like Romeo and Michelle, like I invented Post-its.
这简直就像《阿珠与阿花》里说“我发明了便利贴”一样。
Oh my God.
天哪。
I was like, no, I'm a TV writer, I swear.
我当时就想：不，我真的是个电视编剧，我发誓。
And so I remember when this episode finally aired, I had gotten over the hump and the curse, the curse was reversed.
所以，我记得当这一集终于播出时，我终于熬过了难关，魔咒解除了，魔咒被打破了。
And so.
所以。
But you know what else is weird?
但你知道还有什么奇怪的吗？
The thing you're describing, that kind of liminal state where you're not quite on the air, but you're actually making a living being a TV writer.
你刚才描述的那种状态，那种你并没有真正上星播出，但你确实靠当电视编剧维生的那种边缘状态。
Totally.
完全是这样。
Like in Hollywood, you're weirdly successful.
就像在好莱坞，你诡异地获得了成功。
People in the industry would know exactly what you'd been doing.
业内人士会确切地知道你一直在做什么。
They would even write about the pilots.
他们甚至会写到你写过的试播集。
you wrote on, but like the back home people, the high school friends knowing that your successful Hollywood is a whole different game than Hollywood knowing you're successful.
但就像老家的那些人、高中同学，要让他们知道你在好莱坞很成功，这跟好莱坞知道你很成功完全是两码事。
Totally, totally.
完全如此，完全如此。
And so yeah, I think that like existential idea of like, I'm working hot, like I'm on air, I'm a newscaster, but like nobody sees me, nobody fucking gives a shit.
所以，是的，我觉得那种存在主义式的想法——我在努力工作，我在荧幕上，我是个新闻主播，但没人看我，根本没人他妈的在乎——
Like I think you were telling that.
我觉得你当时就是在讲这个。
I really do.
我真的这么觉得。
I think that's the like nugget of reality.
我认为那是现实的核心所在。
I'm gonna do one.
我要说一个。
That's the kernel of truth.
那是真相的核心。
Kernel of truth.
真相的核心。
stumble upon it, that makes that grounds that story.
偶然发现了它，为那个故事奠定了基础。
And then the story is so much fun off of that.
然后在这个基础上衍生出来的故事就会变得非常有趣。
And it seems like crazy nonsense.
听起来像是疯狂的胡扯。
But there is actually something a little bit true even in that very funny B story.
但即使在那个非常搞笑的B线剧情中，也确实有一点点真实的东西。
And I think those stories, when you come into the room and you tell the story about the existential feeling of going in your history and not being able to prove you, actually, people think you're lying.
我想这些故事，当你走进编剧室，讲起那种回顾历史却无法证明自己的虚无感时，甚至有人会觉得你在撒谎。
She's pretending she's a TV writer.
她是在假装自己是个电视编剧。
That feeling goes into that episode, I think.
那种感觉被融入了那一集里，我是这么认为的。
And that's what I loved about our room.
而这正是我们编剧室最吸引我的地方。
Our room is very confessional, right?
我们的编剧室非常具有自白性质，对吧？
people, you just felt safe telling stories like that.
大家在这里畅所欲言，你就是会觉得倾诉这样的故事很安全。
And then it would lead if somehow it would whether intentionally or not, it would sort of like biosmosis go into a story like that.
然后它就会引导着你，无论是有意还是无意，它就会像渗透作用一样进入这样一个故事中。
I don't even remember if we literally connected that episode of your life to this episode of TV.
我甚至不记得我们是否真的把你的那段人生经历和这一集电视剧联系在了一起。
But I think we did.
但我觉得我们确实联系了。
I think we probably talked all about that idea of like being at the beginning of your career and just wanting so badly to feel like you're important and impressive and the moment you realize you're not.
我想我们可能讨论过那种感觉：处于职业生涯的初期，极其渴望觉得自己很重要、很令人印象深刻，然后在某个瞬间你意识到自己其实并不是。
And that Robin getting to go just completely dead eyed and fall apart inside because she realizes no one watches her at all.
而罗宾却只能彻底面无表情，内心全面崩塌，因为她意识到根本没有人看她的节目。
And then at the end she has like this minor victory of like, well, people did watch.
然后到最后，她算是有了一种小小的胜利，就是，人们确实看了。
This thing where I saw in horses seems to be catching up.
我在马身上看到的这种特质似乎也开始流行起来了。
There's also something nice I imagine.
我想，这也是一件很美好的事。
I'm not I wasn't in a writer in the room.
我当时并没有加入编剧室。
But there must be something kind of weird and nice about having these autobiographical like moments or or sketches like make it onto the air.
但把这些自传性质的时刻或小片段搬上荧幕，感觉一定既奇妙又美好。
And it's not, it's not you, but there's something of like your beating heart and your biography that like went out there and delighted people.
虽然那不是你本人，但你炽热的心和你的生平却通过这种方式传递出去，取悦了观众。
In your first ever produced episode, which is also kind of sweet.
而且这是你制作的第一集，这也挺温馨的。
I totally thought that was your first.
我完全以为那是你的第一部呢。
So what did it feel?
所以感觉怎么样？
I think you've shot that episode at the end of that week.
我想你大概是在那个星期的末尾拍完那一集的吧。
Did it feel like, shit, I'm really a TV writer now.
当时有没有觉得，天哪，我真的是一个电视剧编剧了。
I really, or did it take it?
我真的，还是说需要一点时间？
Did you need it to air?
你是必须等到它播出吗？
The show had to not get cancelled before it aired.
这部剧在播出前可千万不能被砍啊。
I needed it to air like each I was on four shows before this one I didn't get a script one I got a script and I didn't get to shoot it the next one I got to write a script and I got to shoot it and literally when we came to set to shoot it it was Danny Zucker was like guys I have an announcement the show's canceled but we're going to shoot this episode tonight So that's you can imagine the energy must have been through the roof.
我太需要它播出了——在这之前我参与过四部剧，第一部我连剧本都没分到，第二部我分到了剧本但没能拍摄，下一部我分到了剧本也拍了，但 literalmente（字面意思）当我们去片场拍摄时，丹尼·祖克尔（Danny Zucker）就说：“伙计们，我有个通知，剧被砍了，但今晚我们还是要把这集拍完。”所以你可以想象，当时大家的士气肯定高涨到了极点。
When this one finally it was crazy like this was like a wild time for me because this was my first episode that I wrote it made it to TV and I think we aired on a Monday and the Sunday before this aired my no the Saturday before this aired my husband proposed and so like I got engaged my episode aired like I was like wow it's it's all happening like this is like you know and so it was a really and I know you it was really special you had been engaged for other times but never made it to the altar and this was the one this is the one oh and this is fun I was I was remembering this the sock monkeys my husband I remember when we first started dating my husband loved sock Monkeys and he had like he had this like tiny it was like this big like little sock monkey like the sock monkey thing.
当这一集终于……这太疯狂了，对我来说那是一段疯狂的时光，因为这是我写的第一个搬上电视的剧集，我记得我们是在周一播出的，而在这集播出的前一个星期天——不对，是前一个星期六，我丈夫向我求婚了，所以就像是我订婚了，然后我的剧集播出了，当时我就觉得，哇，这一切都在发生，就像是，你知道的，所以那真的是一个……而且我知道你，这真的很特别，你以前也订过几次婚，但从来没走进过婚姻的殿堂，而这次是真的，就是这次，哦，还有一个有趣的事，我当时在想这个，袜猴，我丈夫，我记得我们刚开始约会时，我丈夫非常喜欢袜猴，他有一个像这么大、非常小的袜猴，就是那种袜猴小玩意儿。
I don't think I ever knew that.
我想我以前从不知道这件事。
Shout out to Zach.
向扎克（Zach）致敬。
I love the sock monkeys.
我超爱袜猴。
Yeah.
对。
Inspiration like I remember was like on his shelf and I was like what's this?
灵感来源，我记得它摆在他的架子上，然后我就问：“这是什么？”
He's like I just think sock monkeys are like cute.
他说：“我就是觉得袜猴很可爱。”
Oh, which reminds me.
哦，这让我想起了。
Yeah.
对。
I have a I have a special guest who can join us.
我有一个，我有一位特别的嘉宾要加入我们。
Oh my god.
哦天哪。
Is that it?
就是那个吗？
It's not from the episode.
不是从剧里来的。
That's enough.
这就够了。
This is the the sock monkey.
这就是那个袜猴。
Oh my God.
哦天哪。
That's so great.
太棒了。
That was an excellent reveal for the mystery.
这个悬念揭晓得太精彩了。
Why go to YouTube and watch this this moment.
为什么非要去看YouTube来寻找这个时刻呢。
A gigantic as big as Courtney sock monkey is sitting next to Courtney now.
一个巨大的、和考妮（Courtney）一样大的袜猴现在正坐在考妮旁边。
Was that your pregnancy pillow?
那是你的孕妇枕吗？
It should have been.
本来应该是的。
But yeah, I remember.
不过对，我记得。
Well, that was also fine.
嗯，那也挺好的。
I remember.
我记得。
I think it was like fill Lord.
我想好像是菲尔·洛德（Phil Lord）。
And I think it was like, so it was Dale or Chris or somebody was like, dude, you know, when you're a writer, if If you write shit and do an episode, they have to get it.
我想好像是，要么是戴尔（Dale）要么是克里斯（Chris）或者别的什么人说：“老兄，你知道的，当你是编剧时，如果你写了剧本并制作了一集，他们就得买下它。”
And then you can have it.
然后这东西就归你了。
And then you just take it home.
然后你就可以把它带回家。
So that's what that was.
所以就是这么回事。
That was, they got that, they got that for the episode.
那是，他们把那个，为了那一集拿到了那个。
You didn't bring that to the episode.
你并不是自己把它带到剧组的。
They got that sock one.
他们拿了那个袜猴。
No, they got it.
没有，是他们拿的。
So they said, I'm bringing this home to Zach.
所以他们说，我要把这个带回家给扎克。
And this will be ours.
这个将属于我们。
And you have it almost 20 years later.
而差不多20年后的今天你还留着它。
That's fantastic.
太棒了。
Yeah.
对。
And then I remember Phil and Chris were like, well, did you get the, and I was like, they'll just be like, hey, can I have that sock monkey?
然后我记得菲尔和克里斯说：“哦，你拿到那个了吗？”然后我就想，他们会直接说：“嘿，我能把那个袜猴拿走吗？”
Yeah.
对。
And I was like, I don't know, like, is that allowed?
然后我想，我不知道，这被允许吗？
And you know, just talking about the sock monkeys, that image.
你知道的，说起袜猴，那个画面。
And that like we were saying earlier, like that montage, those montages where you hear balance of bastion and see slow dissolves of like candles and sock monkeys, it becomes a sort of weird abstract indie movie for a minute.
就像我们刚才说的，那个蒙太奇，那些你听着贝尔和塞巴斯蒂安乐队（Belle and Sebastian）的音乐，看着蜡烛和袜猴缓慢淡出的蒙太奇，有那么一分钟，它变成了一部奇怪的抽象独立电影。
That was one of those moments.
那正是其中一个时刻。
And I remember this was an episode where we screened it in front of an audience.
我还记得这是我们在观众面前进行试映的一集。
Remember that Courtney?
还记得吗，考妮？
We would screen to get laughs for the first batch of episodes and it played this played great.
在前几集播出时，我们会进行试映来收集笑声，而这一集的反响好极了。
And I remember feeling like it was so haunting, the disappearing sock monkeys to balance of bastion.
我记得当时觉得那种感觉太迷人了，伴随着贝尔和塞巴斯蒂安的音乐，袜猴渐渐消失。
But then I remember the audience laughed at it.
但我记得观众竟然笑出来了。
Like it was all jokes.
就像是在看喜剧笑话一样。
And I remember like, you're not supposed to laugh at that part.
我当时心想，你们不应该在那部分笑啊。
This is our touching indie movie moment.
这是我们感人的独立电影时刻。
I was like, angry at the audience for laughing, which is really insane.
我对观众的笑声感到有点生气，这真的很疯狂。
But I will say, I hold on to that montage of hearing Belm Sebastian one of my favorite bands.
不过我要说的是，我一直很珍视那个蒙太奇，里面放着我最喜欢的乐队之一贝尔和塞巴斯蒂安的歌。
And that song I chose, that's like one of my favorite Belm Sebastian songs we rule the school.
我选的那首歌，是我最喜欢的贝尔和塞巴斯蒂安的歌之一《We Rule the School》。
And that moment of seeing a weird abstract montage, sock monkeys and Belm Sebastian, I was like, we are a different show.
看到那个奇怪的抽象蒙太奇时刻，袜猴和贝尔和塞巴斯蒂安的音乐，我当时就觉得，我们是一部与众不同的剧。
We are a different kind of sitcom.
我们是一种不同风格的情景喜剧。
we don't quite fit on on CBS all the way.
我们并不完全适合在CBS（哥伦比亚广播公司）播出。
Thank God they stuck with us.
谢天谢地，他们对我们不离不弃。
We were, we were, right?
我们当时，我们确实是，对吧？
We were sandwiched between very different shows on that Monday night comedy lineup.
在那个周一晚上的喜剧档里，我们夹在几部风格迥异的剧集中间。
None of them were doing balance of action and touching montages with disappearing candles and monkeys and I just remember feeling like this, that's the show.
它们可都没有播放贝尔和塞巴斯蒂安的音乐，也没有那种伴随着蜡烛和猴子消失的感人蒙太奇，我只记得当时的感觉就是，这就是这部剧。
That's we have to hold onto that feeling.
这就是我们要紧紧抓住的感觉。
That feeling in that little few seconds of film hold onto that like it is gold and don't go, right?
把电影里这短短几秒钟的感觉紧紧抓住，视若珍宝，千万别弄丢了，对吧？
I told Craig this earlier, Courtney, But I remember I loved balance of action.
我刚才也跟克雷格（Craig）说过这个，考妮，但我记得我超爱贝尔和塞巴斯蒂安。
It was also one of my favorite bands, and I remember reading the script and Feeling like oh my god, I'm on a show that's using a balance of action song as like the central kind of song or theme of the show And I couldn't believe my good fortune that I ended up on a sitcom That would and I really felt like I was in the right I was with my people, you know And when you told me you felt that way I was like I'm so glad we cast Ted as with an actor who loves balance of action And it was one of those, it was, it was, it was, it was us falling in love.
这也是我最喜欢的乐队之一，我记得当时读到剧本时，那种感觉就像是，天哪，我正在拍一部把贝尔和塞巴斯蒂安的歌作为核心歌曲或主题曲的剧，我简直不敢相信自己的好运，竟然能参演这样一部情景喜剧，我真的觉得自己找对了地方，和自己同类的人在一起，你知道的。而当你告诉我你也有这种感觉时，我就觉得，太好了，我们选角时找了泰德（Ted）这样一个热爱贝尔和塞巴斯蒂安的演员，这就是那种，这就是我们坠入爱河的时刻。
Well, the guy who listens to the belt of action is not going to go play laser tag on Saturday night.
嗯，听贝尔和塞巴斯蒂安的人可不会在周六晚上去玩激光枪战。
Like that was.
就像那样的。
Yes.
是的。
Yeah.
对。
You know, it's, yeah.
你知道的，就是这样。
It really defines, it defines Ted and it defines, it defines what's best about the show.
这真正定义了，定义了泰德，也定义了这部剧最棒的地方。
Those little moments.
就是那些小小的时刻。
And episode four, right?
这是第四集，对吧？
We were still finding it.
我们当时还在摸索。
Those moments early on in the series are like the things you say, okay, that's what our show does.
剧集刚开始时的那些时刻，就是你会说“好吧，这就是我们剧的风格”的东西。
Other shows do other things, but our show can do that.
别的剧有别的拍法，但我们的剧可以这样做。
And I think we'll, as we continue to watch the show, we'll see, oh, you guys really figured this out as we went or figured that out.
我想随着我们继续观看这部剧，我们会发现，哦，原来你们是一边拍一边把这些给摸索出来的。
But I think for the first four episodes, it's a really impressive batch of opening jousts.
但我觉得前四集作为一个开局，真的是一组非常惊艳的尝试。
You know, there was a lot that you guys got right or we got right as a team, you know, and everything that ended up becoming kind of a classic kind of how I met your mother.
你知道的，你们有很多地方做对了，或者说我们作为团队做对了，你知道的，最终演变成那种经典《老爸老妈浪漫史》风格的一切。
like the DNA of it is baked into these first four episodes all day.
就像它的基因从一开始就深深植入这前四集里了。
It really is.
确实如此。
Yeah, it really is.
真的确实如此。
And I think this one takes a huge credit.
而且我认为这一集居功至伟。
I didn't think about this until we started talking today of showing ways that Robin was funny, right?
直到我们今天开始聊起怎么展现罗宾搞笑的一面时，我才想到这一点，对吧？
Robin's not just a sought-after perfection and she's not, you know, she's not long for that.
罗宾不仅仅是一个备受追捧的完美女神，而且你知道的，她也不会一直那样。
She's, she's the funniest part of that episode in a lot of ways.
在很多方面，她都是那一集里最好笑的部分。
She's the comic relief.
她是喜剧担当。
She's the comedic engine of it.
她是剧中的喜剧引擎。
For the first time in series.
这是该系列剧的头一遭。
For the first time in series and that's a big deal.
这是剧集历史上头一次，这意义重大。
And how great is Kobe?
而且寇碧有多棒？
I mean, it's just like she's so hilarious in that episode.
我的意思是，她在那一集里简直太搞笑了。
And she was finding it, she had not done much comedy, coming into this series.
而且她也是在摸索中前进，在出演这部剧之前，她没拍过多少喜剧。
She had done a lot of other things, but not much comedy.
她演过很多其他类型的作品，但喜剧不多。
And I think this was the first time where she was like, I get to play.
我想这是她第一次觉得：我终于可以放开玩了。
This is a playground.
这里就像是个游乐场。
I'm taking pratfalls.
我开始摔跟头了。
I'm smacking my ass online.
我在网上拍屁股。
I'm live on a lab newscast.
我在实验室新闻节目里直播。
She just leaned into it.
她完全放飞自我了。
And she was like, okay, I get to do this.
她当时就想，好吧，我可以这么演。
And this was the beginning of her finding so, so much talent at comedy.
这也是她发掘出自己如此巨大的喜剧天赋的开始。
You know what I mean?
你知道我的意思吗？
She felt like someone found it here.
她感觉就像是有人在这里发现了她的潜能。
They felt like someone discovering there.
感觉就像有人在那里发掘了她。
They're like, I'll just do my own stunts.
他们就觉得，我干脆自己上特技吧。
Like she looked like she was like, I don't need pads.
她看起来就像是觉得，我根本不需要护具。
I'm just gonna do this.
我直接上就行。
She had a fearlessness about her.
她身上有一种无所畏惧的劲头。
Yeah, she was a natural.
对，她是个天生的喜剧演员。
It's so fun to see her find that in this episode.
看到她在这一集里展现出这一面，真的太有趣了。
Yes, and especially that end moment with the horse carriage driver.
没错，尤其是最后和马车夫的那个桥段。
He's so sweet and she's so moved by him and her ability to go from the moved emotional caring and then right into the big pratfall is it's so funny.
他太可爱了，而她也被他深深打动，那种从感人至深的情感关怀瞬间切换到大马趴的桥段，实在是太搞笑了。
That was, yeah, that was a delight.
那真的是，太让人赏心悦目了。
I was gonna say, do you have a favorite memory of the shoot week?
我本来想问，你对拍摄那一周有什么特别深刻的记忆吗？
We talked about the writing part.
我们聊过了剧本创作部分。
Does there anything that comes out at you, that night shoot out on the street where she fell?
有什么事是让你印象深刻的吗，比如她摔倒的那次在街上的夜戏？
Those were always fun.
那些总是很有趣。
That was one of our first night shoots out on the New York street that wasn't like a big romantic Tad giving a great speech or something right it was it's funny because like you know the shows that I had been on that didn't work were traditional sitcoms like you know you're in the bar you're in the apartment and you shoot it yeah and I remember this I remember shooting the balance of bastion stuff like the the you know the sack monkeys like Dave Baker pulling away another sack monkey yeah away another sack monkey and I remember like watching it on the monitor and like having the thought like, can we do this?
那是我们在纽约街头拍摄的第一批夜戏之一，不像那种浪漫的大场面——比如泰德发表一段精彩的演讲什么的，对吧，这很有趣，因为你知道，我以前参与过那些没做成功的节目，都是传统的处境喜剧，就像你知道的，你在酒吧里，在公寓里，然后把它拍下来，是的，我记得这个，我记得拍摄那些杂物堆平衡的场景，比如那些麻袋猴——就像戴夫·贝克拿走另一个麻袋猴，对，拿走另一个麻袋猴，我记得在监视器上看着它，然后心里想：我们真的能这么拍吗？
Like there was like a, can we like, will this work?
就像当时心里在想，行得通吗？这能管用吗？
Can you do this?
你能这么做吗？
And I think that voice sometimes like as a creator, it's, it's so damaging.
有时候作为一个创作者，这种内心的声音真的是太具有破坏性了。
Like just fucking do it.
就像——去他的，直接拍不就完了。
You know what I mean?
你知道我的意思吗？
Yeah, it's so refreshing.
对，这种感觉太耳目一新了。
It's exciting to have a scene where like the call sheet says sock monkey.
能拍一场通告单上写着“麻袋猴”的戏，真的让人很兴奋。
And there's no askers in the scene.
而且这场戏里没有其他演员。
It's just like We didn't need the cast for that part.
就像我们那部分根本不需要演员出镜。
Yeah.
对。
I have a crazy story related to this episode.
我有一个和这一集相关的疯狂故事。
And Alec, if this, you can cut this, if it doesn't work.
亚历克，如果这部分不合适，你可以把它剪掉。
But, so Annie Doodak and I who played Natalie, we became very good friends.
是这样的，安妮·杜达克（扮演娜塔莉）和我成了非常要好的朋友。
And one time I wanted to go to Venice to buy this painting for my friend Jesse who was opening a new business and he loved this painting.
有一次我想去威尼斯给我朋友杰西买幅画，他当时正在开创一门新生意，而且他非常喜欢这幅画。
So Annie came with me.
于是安妮就跟我一起去了。
I was gonna buy her brunch.
我答应她只要陪我去买画，我就请她吃早午餐。我们见到了那位艺术家。
If she came with me to buy this painting, we met the artist.
她最后竟然真的嫁给了这位艺术家。
She ended up truly marrying this artist.
她最后嫁给了我带她去见的那个男人。
She ended up marrying the guy that I took her to.
他们现在已经离婚了，但我记得他们育有两个漂亮的孩子。
They're no longer married, but they have two, I think, beautiful children.
而这位艺术家——马修·海勒，当时问我，你在忙什么项目？
And this artist, Matthew Heller, told me, he said, what are you working on?
我说，我在拍《老爸老妈浪漫史》这部剧，其实我和他挺有渊源的，之前就认识。
I said, I'm on the show how I made my mother because I actually ended up, I had known him weirdly.
他说，哦，你们的布景设计师就在你们的片场挂了一幅我的画。
And he said, oh, your set designer has one of my paintings on your set.
我想它就在公寓里。
I think it's in the apartment.
哦，哇。
Oh wow.
壁炉架上的那幅画？
And that painting on the mantle, What is the skyline like is it a?
那里的天际线是什么样的，是那种……
No, it's like an abstract.
不，那是抽象派的。
It's kind of like red and orange.
有点像红色和橙色那种。
Oh, yeah.
哦，对。
Yeah.
对。
对的。
I could point it out But that's just one of this painter Matthew Heller who I took to meet Annie and then they reconnected and then they ended up being married for many years So I thought that was pretty wild.
我能指出来。但这只是其中一个小插曲：这位我带去见安妮的画家马修·海勒，他们后来重新联系上了，最终结为连理，相伴多年。所以我觉得这真的挺离谱的。
Wow.
哇。
Yeah, there's a bunch of that on how I met your mother There's a bunch of weird synergy and like there's like little destiny thing like what the show is about sort of manifested within the making of the show in some ways And Josh, we would never cut that.
对啊，《老爸老妈浪漫史》里有很多这种巧合，有很多奇妙的默契和宿命般的微小细节，某种程度上，这部剧所讲的故事本身就在剧集的制作过程中以某种方式显现出来了。而且乔许，我们绝不会把这部分剪掉，这就是那家伙的孩子们相遇的方式，也就是他是怎么遇到那家伙的孩子们的，没错，正是如此。
That's how that guy's kids met, how he met that guy's kids and that's right.
没错。
That's right.
这非常符合我们剧的风格。
That's a very on-brand.
是的。
Yeah.
这就联系到我妻子考妮说过的话，关于她从你写这一集的那个时候开始的整个人生轨迹，我忘了你是在它播出前夕刚订婚的，这太神奇了。
It connects to my Courtney saying of like her whole life from when you wrote this episode, I forgot that you got engaged literally right before it aired, that's amazing.
你从写的第一个剧集开始，一直到后来2008年（随便哪一集你第九季的最后一集），我们的生活在这部剧播出的九年里一直在继续，而与此同时，我们一直在把生活新篇章中的点点滴滴实时放进剧本里，因为我们和剧中的演员年龄相仿。
You, like from your first episode you wrote to 200 eight later, you know, whatever your last one in season nine was, like our lives kept happening during the nine years of this show, and all the while we were taking things from these new chapters of our lives and putting them in there in real time, because we were the same age as the actors.
这就好比，没错，你生了孩子。
And it's sort of like, right, you had kids.
然后你就开始构思关于当妈妈的笑话和各种想法。
And you're like, now you're pitching jokes and astray ideas about being a mom.
而这一集里，你则是从自己职业生涯艰难时期的奋斗经历中汲取素材，融入到了罗宾的故事线中。
And this was like a career as, you know, you were mining things from your struggle part of your career to put into the Robin story in this episode.
所有这一切都是在现实生活中同步发生的，这真的很有趣。
It's just interesting how in real time all of that was.
我们确实是在挖掘自己的生活并将其演绎出来，就跟在角色身边经历一样，我们总是比角色超前几步。
We were really mining our lives and living them just right alongside, we're like a few steps ahead of the characters.
你我都一样，对吧，因为我也得去……我们都有了孩子，而且很有趣的是，我们几乎是把生活中的点滴按分钟实时转录到了这部电视剧里。
You and I both, right, because I had to go, we both had kids and like it just was interesting how we were kind of almost transcribing our lives up to the minute onto this TV show.
考妮，我有个问题想问你。
Courtney, I have a question for you.
既然你从基本上可以说是第一天一直待到了最后一天，你有没有对这部剧产生某种特殊而深厚的感情？
Since you were on from basically day one until the final day, did you, did you feel some like special deeper connection with the show?
比如你会不会有一种——虽然说不上是所有权——但类似的感觉？
Like did you feel like some, not quite, I don't know if the word is ownership, But like, what was it like to just be there from day one to the final day?
从第一天一直待到最后一天，是一种什么样的体验？
Because I remember you and I had a really sweet moment on the very last day you just came up and you said some lovely things to me and I'll never forget that.
因为我还记得在最后一天，你我之间有过一个非常温馨的时刻，你走过来对我说了一些非常暖心的话，我永远不会忘记。
And I'm just curious, like, what was it like for you when you look back at the whole kind of decade?
我很好奇，当你回首这整整十年时，那是一种什么样的感受？
You know, it honestly, it was such a gift.
说实话，这真的是一份极其珍贵的礼物。
Like, I mean, Craig knows this.
我的意思是，克雷格也知道这一点。
Like, you know, when you're a writer and you're trying to like get your shit together, your agents, you know, you would read all the pilots.
你知道的，当一个编剧正试图理清头绪时，你的经纪人——你会阅读所有的试播集剧本。
And I read this pilot and I was like, I called Lee Sharon Agent Craig and I.
我读了这部剧的试播集剧本，然后我给经纪人李·沙伦还有克雷格打了电话。
And I called my agent and I was like, I am obsessed with this show.
我给我的经纪人打电话说，我迷恋上这部剧了。
Like I, I love this.
我是说，我太喜欢它了。
I think it's so true.
我觉得它太真实了。
I felt like it really spoke to like something I felt.
我觉得它真的说出了我内心深处的一种感受。
Once again, it goes back to like, I am these characters, like these are my friends.
再一次，这又回到了那种感觉：我就是这些角色，这就是我的朋友们。
Like this is what we're going through.
这就是我们正在经历的。
And I was like, I really feel like there's a real thing that were presented this idea that all guys are players and they wanna just be out there having sex.
当时我就想，我觉得我们展现的这种观念非常真实：并非所有男人都是情场浪子，他们满脑子只想寻欢作乐。
And it's like, no, the guys, I know are like good guys who wanna find love.
然后感觉就是，不对，我认识的那些家伙都是想找真爱的好人。
And the girls are all like, we're in the sex in the city now.
而女生们则觉得，我们现在就像《欲望都市》里的女主角一样。
But yeah, yeah.
但是，对，对。
There was like a shift happen, yeah, yeah, totally.
感觉好像发生了一种转变，对，对，完全是这样。
Yeah, there was like, we had the women are in the sex in the city part, but we didn't have the men are looking to settle down.
对，就好像，我们有女性处于《欲望都市》状态的部分，但却没有男性想要安定下来的部分。
point of view, and I was so passionate about it that like, I really did harass my agent who I think in turn harassed me in Carter.
视角，我当时对这个项目充满热情，以至于我真的去死缠烂打我的经纪人，我想他反过来也去死缠烂打卡特了。
I remember feeling very confident in the pilot, because I'm like, I don't know who this Courtney woman is, but she really wants to be on this fucking show.
我还记得对试播集非常有信心，因为我想，我不知道这个叫考特尼的女人是谁，但她是真的很想上这个该死的节目。
I remember feeling, and I remember feeling like it must be good because she's hunting it down.
我记得当时的感觉，而且我觉得这肯定是个好节目，因为她一直在死追不放。
And you really were, now Courtney, tell, I think this is when this line was said, our shared agent Matt Rice, one of the greats, what, when you were so excited about the pilot, and I mean, really wrestled in true elbows to get in the room for a meeting with us when the show was getting picked up.
你确实是这样的，现在考特尼，说说看，我想就是在这个时候说出了那句话，我们的共同经纪人马特·赖斯，一位业界大佬，什么，当你对试播集如此兴奋的时候，我的意思是，当节目快要被预定的时候，你真的在会议室里跟我们据理力争，想要挤进来开会。
What didn't Matt Rice?
马特·赖斯没说什么吗？
What was Matt Rice's advice to you when you before you came to the meeting with me and Carter?
在你来我和卡特的会议之前，马特·赖斯给你的建议是什么？
Am I getting this right?
我没记错吧？
You know what I mean, yeah?
你知道我的意思，对吧？
Yeah.
对。
What did he say?
他说了什么？
You gotta say.
你得说说。
Because it became a catchphrase in the writer's room.
因为这成了编剧室里的口头禅。
For a long time.
持续了很长时间。
It became a catchphrase.
它成了一个流行语。
And he was like, Kang, our agent is amazing.
他说，康，我们的经纪人太棒了。
Like I love him.
我很喜欢他。
He's like, he's like, amfing me up.
他一直在给我打气。
He's like, Kang, it's gonna be awesome.
他说，康，这节目会超棒的。
I'm like, get in there.
我说，进去吧。
Like show your enthusiasm, don't hold back, tell them how much you love this, have your jokes ready, be amped up.
展现你的热情，别拘束，告诉他们你有多喜欢这个，准备好你的笑话，兴奋起来。
I mean, don't Courtney Kang all over the place.
我是说，别到处都是考特尼·康那种风格。
Don't Courtney Kang all over the place.
别到处都是考特尼·康那种风格。
And I was like, wait, wait, what's, what's, what's, what's Courtney Kang all over the place?
当时我就想，等等，等等，什么叫到处都是考特尼·康那种风格？
Okay, all over the place.
好吧，就是各种大惊小怪。
And then I, oh, I think we were in the meeting, we started talking or something.
然后我，哦，我想我们在开会的时候，开始聊天什么的。
And somehow we started talking about, like, NC Hammer, the typewriter.
不知怎么的，我们开始聊起，比如，MC·哈默，打字机。
And I think some, what, like, Carter's, and I was like, was like, what's that?
然后我想，什么，卡特的，我就问，那是什么？
And so I, like, jump up and I start doing that, like, NC Hammer, like, top typewriter.
然后我，就像，跳了起来，开始模仿那个，MC·哈默式的，那种打字机舞步。
Oh my God.
我的天啊。
And it's right as I'm, like, this point, I was like, oh, this is Courtney Cainey.
就在我做这个动作的时候，我想，哦，这就是考特尼·康式风格。
I love this.
我太喜欢这个了。
We love you, Courtney, we're so happy you were able to join us.
我们爱你，考特尼，非常高兴你能加入我们。
I got married last year, And my wife has never seen how I met your mother.
我去年结婚了，我妻子从来没看过《老爸老妈浪漫史》。
So that was part of the impetus for doing this show was she really wanted to watch it and fill in this chapter of my life that she never got to witness.
所以这也是我制作这个节目的动力之一，她真的很想看，并填补我人生中她从未经历过的那段空白。
So we were watching it together and we have a segment that we don't have an acronym for it yet.
所以我们一直在一起看，我们有一个环节，目前还没给它起个缩写名字。
But it's something like questions and observations from a psychologist and relationship expert who's never seen how I met your mother who also happens to be married to Josh.
但它差不多就是：来自一位从未看过《老爸老妈浪漫史》、碰巧又嫁给乔什的心理学家兼恋爱专家的提问与观察。
Something like that.
差不多就是这样。
I love it.
我太喜欢了。
Yeah.
对。
Right, Ronald's off the tongue.
没错，说起来还挺顺口的。
Exactly.
没错。
We wanted something pithy.
我们想要个精炼点的名字。
So she's sometimes will just tell me what her question is.
所以她有时候会直接把问题告诉我。
Sometimes she'll record a voice memo.
有时候她会录一段语音备忘录。
I have not even heard this one.
这一条我甚至还没听过。
I just sent it to Alec, but I don't know what this is.
我只是把它发给了亚历克，但我不知道这是什么。
So let's hear it.
那我们来听听吧。
I think this episode touches upon one of the age-old questions regarding romantic love.
我认为这一集触及了关于浪漫爱情的永恒问题之一。
Is this the wrong person, or is it just the wrong time?
这是错的人，还是只是错的时间？
I hear patients ponder this frequently.
我经常听到患者思考这个问题。
I think most of us have come across that issue with someone we've dated at one point or another, but I'm wondering as artists, if maybe you also have this with creative projects, so my question is, what is your return of the shirt if you're willing to share with an idea, a concept, or a script that didn't work out in the moment, but you fantasize could potentially work now.
我想我们大多数人在过去的某段约会经历中都遇到过这个问题，但我想知道作为艺术家，你们在创意项目上是否也会遇到这种情况，所以我的问题是，如果愿意与大家分享的话，有没有哪个想法、概念或剧本，当时行不通，但你幻想它现在有可能奏效，这就像是你的“退还衬衫”环节？
Wow.
哇。
That's a mind blowing question.
这是一个让人脑洞大开的问题。
Wow.
哇。
Yeah.
对。
Well, I think that is a true theme of the episode.
嗯，我觉得这确实是这一集的主题。
It's like, you mentioned this actually, like I've changed maybe my perspective on this relationship change.
就像，你其实也提到了这一点，比如我对这种关系的看法改变了。
She changed because certainly, I mean, you hear stories all the time like we dated in college and it was disaster and we reconnected in our mid 30s and it was great.
她改变了，因为当然，我的意思是，你总是听到这样的故事：我们在大学时约过会，那是一场灾难，然后在我们三十岁出头时又重新联系上了，结果好极了。
You know, and I think that's what Ted is holding out for.
你知道的，我想这也是泰德一直在等待的。
But I think Jordan has a question around creativity like I don't know if you guys are the same way, but I always have so many tabs open Like I have so many projects that are kind of in various stages of completion or disarray and Sometimes something is just sitting there half-formed and it just won't catch fire and other times something that was sitting there I'll be re-inspired and it'll just the heat will be there and I'll and I'll be able to finish it and maybe make it and I think sometimes like I try to honor honor the piece of art or the script or the song as having its own kind of arc and intelligence and knowledge about when it's going to be ready.
但我觉得乔丹提出的问题是关于创造力的，我不知道你们是不是也这样，但我总是开着太多网页标签，也就是说，我有太多项目处于不同的完成阶段或混乱状态，有时候某个东西就那么半成形地摆在那里，就是无法擦出火花；而有时候，对于那些放在那里的东西，我会重新获得灵感，热情就会涌现，然后我就能把它完成并创作出来。所以我觉得有时候，我试着去尊重一件艺术品、一个剧本或一首歌，把它当成有自己独特的弧光、智慧以及对何时准备就绪的自我认知的生命。
So I really try to be in dialogue with the thing like, are you ready to open up to me, or am I ready to put the work in on this?
所以我真的很努力地与这个作品进行对话，比如，你准备好向我敞开了吗，或者我准备好为之付出努力了吗？
So I've had things that have sat around for a while.
所以有些东西我搁置了很久。
I just finished the last song from my album that I'm recording now.
我刚刚完成了现在正在录制的专辑里的最后一首歌。
I started it on my honeymoon in April.
我在四月份的蜜月期间开始创作它。
And it was just I would write like a first a month, you know, like, and other songs you sit down and they're, they're done in 20 minutes, like, but I, I, I really try to honor the thing and let it be.
当时的情况就是，我可能一个月才写出第一段，你知道的，而有些歌你一坐下来，20分钟就写完了，但我，我，我真的很尊重这个创作本身，顺其自然。
But I, I don't, I don't throw anything away because I feel like there might be a day where it calls me back.
不过我，我，我从不扔掉任何东西，因为我觉得总有一天它会呼唤我回去。
And the debate is always, is it a good idea to go back?
而争论的焦点总是，回去找它真的是个好主意吗？
It's very much from the show because sometimes you go back to an idea and you have 10 to the moment Ted has of, dear God, I've got to get out of this.
这非常符合剧中的情节，因为有时你重新审视一个想法时，你会经历泰德那种“天啊，我得赶紧离开这儿”的时刻。
Why did I go that totally?
我为什么会完全走那条路？
Or you remember, you remember why you got stuck and threw it away or stopped working on it.
或者你会记起来，记起你当初为什么卡壳并把它扔掉或停止创作。
Yeah, you know, that would happen all the time in the room.
对，你知道的，在编剧室里这种事经常发生。
Like, we would be like, oh, we had an idea about, you know, the gang goes to the mall.
比如，我们会说，哦，我们有个点子，关于，你知道的，大家一起去商场。
Oh, yeah, there was all this great stuff.
哦，对，有所有这些超棒的内容。
There was all this stuff.
有所有这些内容。
And then you pull up the notes and it was like, the gang goes to the mall and was like, that's what we had.
然后你翻开笔记一看，上面写着：大家一起去商场，然后就没有了，这就是我们当时所有的内容。
Was it more?
还有别的吗？
You remember it sort of more fun.
你记忆中的感觉要有趣得多。
Yeah, we were ready to shrink that mall thing down to just a fake pop song by a Canadian pop Yeah, it's true.
对，我们当时准备把那个商场的情节缩减成一个加拿大流行歌手创作的虚构流行歌曲，对，确实如此。
That feeling of going back to the room notes of something, and you go, like, that was excellent.
那种重新翻看以前的房间笔记的感觉，然后你会说，太棒了。
That was cool.
这太酷了。
This is going to catch fire.
这绝对能火。
And you sit there for a whole day.
然后你在那里坐了一整天。
And it's basically, I've got to get out of this.
基本上就是：我得赶紧离开这儿。
I've got to.
我必须离开。
And there isn't energy to these things.
这些东西根本没有能量。
There isn't energy.
没有能量。
And things have a time.
每样东西都有它的时候。
I agree completely, Josh.
我完全同意，乔什。
I've gotten very, like, woo, woo, about creative stuff, way of the two.
关于创作方面的东西，我也变得非常玄学，顺其自然。
It's like, there's a time you shouldn't have to force it too much.
这就好像，时机到了，你就不应该强求太多。
If something calls you back, you have to be honest.
如果有什么东西再次召唤你，你必须诚实面对。
Do you want to go back to that thing?
你真的想回到那个东西上去吗？
And Ted was not, it was yet again in this episode.
而泰德并没有，在本集中他又一次面临这种情况。
Ted was not honest with himself.
泰德对自己的内心不够诚实。
He just wanted the shortcut to feeling like, and she'll be the one, and she'll be answering.
他只是想要找到捷径，去感觉“就是她了，她会给出回应”。
He's rushing, and he was not honest with himself about it.
他在急于求成，而且他对此并没有对自己坦诚。
And I think there is a parallel between relationships and art where, I think there's this very American idea of like, relationships are work.
而且我认为感情和艺术之间存在一种相似之处，我觉得有一种非常美国式的观念，那就是：感情就是工作。
They require work and art requires work.
它们需要付出努力，艺术也需要付出努力。
And you got a grind away and grind away and work, work, work.
你必须不断地苦干、苦干，不停地工作、工作、工作。
And I actually think that effortlessness is undervalued in both relationships and art.
但实际上我认为，在感情和艺术中，“毫不费力”这种特质都被低估了。
Like, we've all caught a wave, where writing just feels like our fingers are being moved rather than we're moving them, where you really feel like something's just, you're capturing it, it's just coming through you.
比如，我们都曾有过那种状态，写作时感觉手指仿佛是在被推动着，而不是我们在移动它们，你会真切地觉得有什么东西正在涌现，你正在捕捉它，它只是通过你流淌出来。
And in the same way, I struggled in relationships for so long and it really did feel like work.
同样地，我在感情中挣扎了那么久，那真的感觉像是在工作。
And then I still have work with my wife.
然后我和我妻子之间也依然有需要磨合的地方。
It's still, you still have to put forth the effort, you have to apologize when you screwed up all these things.
依然如此，你还是得付出努力，搞砸了的时候你得道歉，诸如此类。
But there is a kind of ease and effortlessness when I, when I'm with her that feels new and different and like kind of what I was looking for without being able to even say that at the time because I didn't know that.
但和她在一起时，有一种自然而然的轻松感和毫不费力的默契，这感觉很新鲜、很不一样，就像是我一直在寻找的，只是当时连自己都说不清楚，因为我并不知道。
Well, Josh, Jordan never gets upset at you.
好吧，乔什，乔丹可从来没生过你的气。
She now knows she can go watch a lot of footage of you getting the shit kicked out of you, starting with episode four.
她现在知道自己可以去看很多关于你被打得落花流水的视频了，从第四集开始。
We're trying to shirt.
我们正打算穿衬衫。
She's like, I'm a little pissed at Josh.
她说：“我有点生乔什的气。”
I'm like, why do you have a montage of Ted most beginning to be beaten up.
我说：“你为什么会有一段泰德挨揍的混剪视频呢？”
So after our launch yesterday, we received incredible messages from all around the world.
所以昨天节目上线后，我们收到了来自世界各地不可思议的留言。
They came to us from my newsletter or sub-stack page, from the Oomium sub-stack page, from Instagram at how we made your mother, and from our website.
它们来自我的通讯稿或Substack页面、Oomium的Substack页面、Instagram上的“how we made your mother”账号，以及我们的网站。
And we're reading them all, and we're so grateful to everyone for taking the time to tell us what how I met your mother means to you.
我们正在阅读所有的留言，非常感谢大家抽出时间来告诉我们《老爸老妈浪漫史》对你们意味着什么。
This one is from Amy, and it was a response to the sub-stack that I wrote on my newsletter.
这条留言来自艾米，它是对我在个人通讯稿上写的Substack文章的回应。
And she writes, the show came out the year after I first got married and had my second child.
她写道，这部剧在我结婚并有了第二个孩子的第二年开播。
But it took a few years for me to watch.
但我过了几年才开始看。
First watch was when Netflix still did Mail DVDs, LOL.
第一次看的时候，Netflix还提供邮寄DVD的服务，哈哈。
The characters were the exact age I was, slash AM in all the years that happened, loved that.
剧中的角色和我当时（或者说在剧集发生的那些年里）的年龄一模一样，太喜欢这一点了。
In my late teens, early 20s, I was a friends fan, watched with my mom, and even got to go to set there at one point, but they were 10 years older than me, so hymnium solidified more with me.
在我十几岁到二十出头的时候，我是《老友记》的粉丝，和妈妈一起看，甚至还去过那部剧的片场，但他们比我大10岁，所以《老爸老妈浪漫史》更能引起我的共鸣。
There's so much realism philosophy in it.
里面有那么多的现实主义哲学。
My best friend, who's 10 years younger than me, loves it as well.
我最好的朋友比我小10岁，她也很喜欢这部剧。
And one example of the greatness slash realism, she often brings up is the one curly fry, LOL.
她经常提起的一个展现其伟大之处或现实主义的例子，就是那根卷曲的薯条，哈哈。
We both are huge romantics like Ted, but we've been through some rough relationships and had to realize we had some codependent issues.
我们俩都和泰德一样是超级浪漫主义者，但我们都经历过一些糟糕的感情，不得不意识到自己有一些共情依赖的问题。
And other things we've worked out in therapy and Coda groups shout out to Coda and therapy.
以及我们在心理治疗和CoDA（匿名共依存症互助会）小组中解决的其他问题，向CoDA和心理治疗致敬。
So that has changed some perspective on the characters and things on the show but doesn't make us love it any less.
所以这改变了我们对剧中角色和一些事情的看法，但并没有减少我们对它的喜爱。
The show is cathartic.
这部剧具有宣泄情绪的作用。
It's a night watch still.
它依然是深夜必看的节目。
Sometimes I go from the first episode to the last but often I let Alexa or Siri choose a number of the season and for the season in episode.
有时我从第一集看到最后一集，但通常我会让Alexa或Siri随机选择一个季数以及具体的某一集。
Sometimes I go to a specific episode if I need to think back on something or process some feelings.
有时如果我需要回想某些事情或处理一些情绪，我会去看特定的一集。
I choreographed a yellow umbrella ballet a lobby on Rose last year.
我去年在露丝街的大厅里编排过一出黄伞芭蕾。
Oh my god.
天呐。
I've danced to your songs.
我跳过你们的歌。
Can you send up a clip of that?
你能发一段那个的片段过来吗？
Please send us a clip of that.
请发一段那个的片段给我们吧。
I've danced to your songs and many other pivotal songs from the show.
我跳过你们的歌，还有剧中许多其他关键歌曲。
I have pop culture, him, you reminders, peppered throughout my house, shower curtains, earrings, pictures.
我的家里到处都是流行文化、他、你的纪念品，比如浴帘、耳环、照片。
I never don't cry a **** for the **** Robyn saying **** the speech Ted gives **** before **** because so often I've wanted to time travel or skip ahead to adjust things.
每次看到罗宾说脏话、泰德在……之前发表的演讲，我都忍不住落泪，因为我常常想时光倒流或快进以调整一些事情。
Though ultimately they happen as they should.
尽管它们最终都会按照应有的方式发生。
All just so relatable.
所有这一切都太有共鸣了。
I've always been fascinated with the subject of fate, destiny, free will.
我一直对命运、天意和自由意志这些主题很着迷。
There's private reasons about who I watched the show with that also tie me to my love of the show.
因为我和谁一起看这部剧，还有一些个人的原因，这也将我对这部剧的喜爱紧密连结在一起。
It just is different than any other show, and we'll always have a huge place of comfort and love in my heart.
它就是与众不同，超越了其他任何剧集，并永远在我心中占据着一个充满温暖与爱的重要位置。
Thank you, Amy.
谢谢你，艾米。
That's so.
太……
Thank you, Amy.
谢谢你，艾米。
Lovely.
太美好了。
So nice.
太棒了。
And honestly, please do send us the footage of that dance you were going on.
说实话，请务必把刚才提到的那段舞蹈素材发给我们。
Yeah, I'd be really happy.
对，我真的很乐意看。
And if you're listening, if you want to get your voice on the podcast, we'd love to hear from you go to how we made your mother dot com go to contact and record your actual voice and tell us what how we made your mother means to you.
如果你正在收听，如果你想在播客中发出自己的声音，我们非常欢迎你联系我们，访问 howwemadeyourmother.com 点击联系，录下你真实的声音，告诉我们《如何与你母亲相遇》对你意味着什么。
How we made your mother is hosted and executive produced by Josh Radner and Craig Thomas.
《如何与你母亲相遇》由乔什·雷德诺和克雷格·托马斯主持并担任执行制片人。
The show was produced by me, Alec Lem, and our co-producer is Doug Matica.
本节目由我，亚历克·莱姆制作，我们的联合制片人是道格·马蒂卡。
Our audio producer and mixer is Alex Reeves at Point of Blue Studios, artwork by John Marrow.
我们的音频制作人和混音师是 Point of Blue Studios 的亚历克斯·里夫斯，封面插图由约翰·马罗绘制。
Please follow, rate, and review the show on Apple Podcasts or your podcast player of choice.
请在苹果播客或你首选的播客平台上关注、打分并评价本节目。
It really does help the show.
这真的对节目很有帮助。
Our theme song is NYC by our own Josh Radner, special thanks to Lola Kennedy and Elliott Connards.
我们的主题曲是《NYC》，由我们自己的乔什·雷德诺创作，特别感谢罗拉·肯尼迪和埃利奥特·康纳兹。
Visit howwemadeyourmother.com to sign up for our sub-stack mailing list and for links to our social media.
访问 howwemadeyourmother.com 注册我们的 Substack 邮件列表，并获取我们社交媒体的链接。
You can also click on the contact page to send us an email or a voice message.
你也可以点击联系页面给我们发邮件或语音留言。
Your stories and questions are an important part of the show.
你们的故事和问题是本节目不可或缺的重要部分。
Subscribe to Josh Riders' newsletters on Substack, read Craig Thomas' published prose at CraigThomasRider.com and you can subscribe to my Dead Fathers Society also on Substack.
欢迎在 Substack 上订阅乔什·雷德诺的时事通讯，在 CraigThomasRider.com 阅读克雷格·托马斯出版的散文，你也可以同样在 Substack 上订阅我的“已故父亲协会”。
To learn about how you make a difference, this shows ongoing campaign to raise money for a congenital heart disease research.
要了解如何为本节目筹集先天性心脏病研究资金的持续慈善活动贡献力量，
Check out the Make a Difference tab at the top of our website.
请查看我们网站顶部的“创造改变”标签页。
This episode was made possible by the support of Backyard Ventures, marketing provided by Tink Media.
本集的制作得到了 Backyard Ventures 的支持，营销由 Tink Media 提供。
will in fact dance.
最后确实跳了舞。